Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Kraftwerk nach Zahlen, an jedem letzten Donnerstag im Monat ist es wieder so weit. Das Chaos Radio übernimmt für zwei Stunden hier die Frequenzen von Fritz und möglicherweise auch den Livestream vielleicht oder so. Das heißt, Leute vom Chaos Radio sind da und sprechen über ein Thema, was sich möglicherweise auch mal aufgedrängt hat. Ich begrüße heute den Herrn Erdgeist. Hallo, den Herrn Andy Müller-Maguhn. Und den Herrn Linus Neumann.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und man hat es vielleicht unter Umständen schon erraten können, es geht heute um...
Fernmelde über Wachung.
Ja genau, also auf alte sagen. Es geht heute um die Wachung, Überwachung eurer Telekommunikation. Aber man könnte jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile... Ich bin schon mal ganz sicher. Ich bin schon mal ganz sicher, dass es eine andere Art ist. Ich bin schon mal ganz sicher, dass es eine andere Art ist. Ich bin schon mal ganz sicher, dass es eine andere Art ist.
Ich bin schon mal ganz sicher, dass es eine andere Art ist.
Außerdem haben wir das eh schon alle gewusst. Da ist ja nur kein großes Geheimnis. Es gab also im Guardian und in der Washington Post zwei größere Zeitungen der ersten Welt die Enthüllung. Da ging es zuerst um die NSA. Das ist der, korrigiert mich, welcher Geheimdienst ist das? Militärische Auslands?
Das ist der für die Fernmeldeüberwachung zuständige Nachrichtendienst der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika.
Und der überwacht alle Telekommunikationen, hieß es auf einmal. Also wirklich alle. Was genau heißt das?
Das heißt, dass unser Moderator das völlig falsch wiedergegeben hat. Prism ist nur ein ganz kleines Projekt in diesem ganz großen Kontext. Prism hat halt gegenüber von Boundless Informer und Tempora und anderen interessanten Begriffen den Vorteil, dass es ein kurzes Wort ist, dass die Öffentlichkeit den einfachen Wiedererkennungswert hat. Das ist wie so ein Brandname. Aber Prism ist nur der Filter aus der Totalüberwachung für die Sozialnetze. Also für sowas wie Facebook, Google und Twitter und so fort. Der eigentliche sozusagen Apparat nimmt halt weltweit alles mit, was er kriegen kann, speichert das auch vollständig. Das heißt, hier wird nicht mehr gezielt irgendjemand überwacht, sondern man nimmt einfach alles mit, was man kriegen kann und dann filtern die eben mit verschiedenen Programmen und visualisieren mit verschiedenen Programmen raus. Zum Beispiel, wer mit wem telefoniert, wer mit wem E-Mailverkehr und Sonstiges hat, das was man als Metadaten oder als Verkehrsdaten auch bezeichnet. Und ja.
Jetzt hast du ja quasi die zwei Stunden, die wir jetzt eigentlich geplant hatten, schon mal sozusagen sehr abstrakt zusammengefasst. Aber die Frage ist ja, was ist genau passiert? Und ich habe mit Prism angefangen, weil das ja auch das ist, was als erstes das Licht der Öffentlichkeit erblickt hat.
Ja, naja, weil der Guardian sich natürlich auch überlegt hat, womit holt man jetzt die Leute ab, wo sie sind. Nämlich mit Sachen, die sie kennen. Facebook kennt jeder, Twitter kennt jeder, Google kennt jeder. Und da ließ ich natürlich das erst mal schön erklären. Aber die eigentliche Problematik besteht wirklich darin, dass der Anspruch der US-Dienste und nicht nur der Anspruch, sondern wohl auch die technische Realität anmählich so weit ist, dass die in etlichen Ländern und an vielen Verbindungen zwischen Ländern wirklich jedwede Kommunikation mitnehmen, speichern, auswerten und die einer Verwertung zu führen. Und diese Verwertung, die ist halt nicht unbedingt so klar, ob es da wirklich um Terrorismusbekämpfung oder irgendetwas geht oder ob es da vielleicht auch um wirtschaftliche Interessen geht, um Börsenmanipulation, um Ausnutzung von Kenntnissen, von Zuständen, die erst viel später öffentlich werden, von politischen sonstigen Situationen, die halt so einen Machtapparat wie den, den die Vereinigten Staaten versuchen, darzustellen, auch wenn das jetzt sozusagen im Moment ein König ohne Kleider ist, als supranationale Macht mit was sie so spielen.
Ich würde trotzdem gerne nochmal zum Anfang zurückkehren.
Der Anfang?
Also der Anfang von dieser Enthüllungsgeschichte. Wir haben ja dann noch zwei Stunden Zeit, um die Details auseinanderzuklamüsern. Aber was genau wissen wir denn jetzt über Prism?
Über Prism haben wir ja Auszüge aus den Präsentationen. Und wir wissen, dass Prism ein Programm ist, was ich müsste jetzt mal genau gucken, wann das eingeführt wurde. Siehe Bug Planet und da in die Suchzeile kurz Prism eingehen. Da gibt es diese Slides. Die Präsentation ist von April diesen Jahres. Und bezieht sich halt auf die Auswertung von Daten bei Gmail, Facebook, Yahoo, Google, Skype, OL, YouTube, Paltalk und irgendwas anderes noch, was ich nicht genau erkennen kann.
Wobei muss man dazu sagen, dass Paltalk groß geworden ist, weil es während des sogenannten Arabischen Frühlings intensiv benutzt worden ist.
Was ist das?
Das ist so auch ein soziales Netzwerk.
Gleich auf der zweiten Folie wird dann mit genug Tugend festgestellt, dass die meiste Internetkommunikation des Planeten durch die USA durchfließt. Sei es von Europa, Afrika, Asien, Lateinamerika oder den Vereinigten Staaten selbst. Und dass es deswegen relativ einfach ist, dort mit diesem Filterprogramm, mit diesem Prism eben aus diesen ganzen Diensten dann E-Mails, Chats, Videos, Fotos, gespeicherte Daten, Voice-over-IP, also Telefongespräche, Dateitransfer, Videokonferenzen und so fort eben die ganzen Funktionalitäten dieser verschiedenen Anbieter rauszufiltern, zu extrahieren und wegzuspeichern.
Aber wie machen Sie das? Also wie kommen Sie denn die Daten ran? Setzen Sie sich dann zwischendurch mit Ihrem fetten Arsch auf die Leitung und fangen das auf oder wie kommen Sie denn die Sachen überhaupt ran?
Naja, eine der Geschichten, die ja jetzt in den letzten Tagen konkret... Andy, bevor du...
also ich weiß, mit dem Abhören ist das nicht so gut, aber wenn du dichter ans Mikrofon gehen würdest, dann könnten dich besser abhören.
Na vielleicht könnten Sie mir sogar zuhören. Okay, also eine der... Also jetzt abgesehen davon, dass innerhalb von den USA, das ist ja auch schon eine Zeit lang bekannt, bei den großen Service-Providern eben direkt die Fasern alle nochmal zur NSL rübergehen, ist ja eine der Sachen, die in den letzten Tagen klar geworden ist, dass beispielsweise England, aber eben auch andere Länder, die als Partner in diesem NSL-Spiel mitspielen, jedwede Verbindung, die in das Land rein und rausgehen, also die internationalen Glasfaserverbindungen, eben mit abschnorcheln und in diesen NSL-Apparat sozusagen mit reinfieten. Aber wie?
Na ja wie? Also ich meine, da gibt es halt Kabel und...
Es gibt irgendwie auch in Deutschland nach der TKÜV, nach der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung, müssen alle Telekommunikationsanbieter mit mehr als 10.000 Kunden Abhörschnittstellen zur Verfügung stellen. Das heißt, da müssen gesonnerte Räume sein, in die die Techniker da rein und raus können der jeweiligen Bedarfsträger, um dort Abhör-Equipment zu installieren. Und vor allem muss es auch so installiert werden, dass jeweils andere Bedarfsträger nicht mitbekommen, dass da schon ein Abhörvorgang stattfindet auf einen bestimmten Anschluss zum Beispiel. Und der Betreiber selber darf es auch nicht mitbekommen.
Wenn da von Räumen gesprochen wird, müssen wir sozusagen beim Telekommunikationsbetreiber ein tatsächliches Zimmer vorstellen, wo Technik drinsteht oder ist das so ein Code für, es gibt irgendwie einen Zugang zum System und da kam dann irgendjemand rein?
Ich bin kein Jurist, aber ich denk mal es kommt drauf an.
Die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung ist eigentlich das, was man taktische Überwachung nennt. Das heißt, hier geht es darum, dass ein einzelner Anschluss oder Anschlussinhaber aufgrund von irgendwelchen vorliegenden Vorerkenntnissen, dass er eben einer Straftat verdächtigt wird oder eine Gefahr für die äußere Sicherheit darstellt oder was auch immer abgehört werden soll. Das heißt, hier geht es aber um einzelne Anschlüsse.
Ich glaube gerade, dass die Anschlüsse überhaupt die Schnittstellen darliegen.
Ich sage nur ganz kurz, das ist ein bisschen zu unterscheiden von dem, was man strategische Überwachung nennt, das eben im nachrichtendienstlichen Bereich stattfindet, wo tatsächlich die komplette Kommunikation mitgenommen wird. Und das geschieht beispielsweise eben durch Biegekoppler. Das sind so die Glasfasern, die kann man, das kann man sich so vorstellen wie so eine Art, ja, 180 Grad Kurve, die man mit einer Glasfaser macht. Und dann kommen da Photonen raus und die kann man auffangen. Das heißt, das ist eine Technik um Glasfasern.
Warte, warte, warte, ganz bildlich gesprochen. Also man nimmt wirklich ein Kabel und biegt das einmal, sodass man eine Schlaufe hat und dann schießen da Photonen raus, die man abhören kann?
Na ja, Glasfaser ist ja ein optisches Übertragungsverfahren, wo durch Lichtsignale codierte digitale Informationen in Hochgeschwindigkeit übertragen werden. Und diese Lichtgeschwindigkeit, die man licht, ist ja nichts anderes als Photonen, die da durchgeschoben werden. Kann man halt, indem man diese Faser, wie gesagt, biegt, kann man die rausholen. Das heißt, man muss jetzt nicht mal durchschneiden und wieder verbinden, weil das würde ja auffallen. Dann würden die Leute ja merken, dass da mal die Verbindung weg war. Und so fort. Sondern man kann tatsächlich im laufenden Betrieb so eine Faser geschickt durch so einen kleinen Apparat schicken. Und dann kann man alles, was da durchgeht, auch nochmal woanders hin schicken.
Ein bisschen fällt es schon auf, weil man da plötzlich Dämpfung auf der Leitung hat. Aber die meisten messen gar nicht nach, ob da irgendjemand vielleicht noch mit drauf sitzt.
Aber vielleicht fangen wir doch mal ganz kurz noch ein bisschen mit den einfacheren Methoden an.
Warte mal, jetzt muss ich aber, wenn wir schon an der Stelle sind, noch eine kurze Nachfrage stellen. Die kannst du auch gerne gleich beantworten. Dieses kleine Gerät, mit dem man da die Photonen aus dem Kabel aufhängt, ist das jetzt so, wir basteln uns das aus dem Heimwerkermarkt, oder ist das eher so, da wirft mal irgendeine staatliche Behörde 300 Millionen irgendwo hin?
Vielleicht nicht 300 Millionen, aber das ist schon High-Tech. Okay, eher High-Tech. Das ist dann so Cutting Edge.
Okay, also James Bond hat das und die Geheimnisse.
Am Ende muss man das auch nicht, aus den früheren Tagen sind ja Fälle bekannt, wo so ein U-Boot einfach sich ein Kabel schnappt, kupfer und dann einfach klonk ran und schauen, was da transferiert wird. Und da muss man nicht unbedingt jetzt zu dem Provider hingehen und eben sein Kabel da vor Ort biegen. Das kann man auch machen, ohne dass der das mitbekommt.
Also Kupferkabel, das ist ja schon nie was anderes. Das könnte man wahrscheinlich durch die magnetische Abstrahlung dann irgendwie ausmessen oder muss man da ran?
Da gibt es mannigfaltige Möglichkeiten, aber...
Okay, kommen wir jetzt wirklich zu den einfachen. Herr Neumann.
Also fangen wir mal einfach an, bevor wir jetzt in U-Boote steigen und so, was Erdgeist gerade schon ansprach, in solchen Rechenzentrumen stehen dann tatsächlich dieses Equipment, von dem verlangt ist, dass natürlich, das macht ja auch Sinn, der Betreiber dieser Infrastruktur selber soll ja nicht sehen, wen, wer jetzt gerade überwacht wird. Also ich betreibe zum Beispiel einen, nennen wir mal, Dollar-Netz, ja? Und dann soll ich natürlich nicht erfahren, was das Equipment, was mir da der Dollar-Geheimdienst reingestellt hat, wen das gerade überwacht und wonach das gerade sucht. Das wäre ja eine Information, die bei mir ein Whistleblower oder ein nicht vertrauenswürdiger Angestellter irgendwie missbrauchen könnte. Die relativ einfache Lösung, die man sich da hat einfallen lassen, ich habe mal das Glück gehabt, mir so ein Rechenzentrum anschauen zu dürfen, und habe dann gefragt, naja, sag doch mal, wo steht denn hier euer Lawful Intercept Kram? Also wo sitzt hier der Start? Und was ich da gesehen habe, war dann so ein Rack, also ein Schrank, und da waren Geräte drin und diese Geräte waren nichts anderes als Switches. Also ganz normale Vermittlungsstellen in so einem Netzwerk, die einfach nur dafür zuständig sind, das eine Kabel mit dem anderen zu verbinden und so dafür zu sorgen, dass die ganzen Internetpakete vom einen Anschlussinhaber zu ihrem Ziel kommen. So ein Switch hat aber auch immer noch ein Monitoring Port. Das heißt, das ist der Port, auf dem alle Pakete sowieso nochmal rausfallen. Das heißt, da gibt er einfach nochmal alles ab. Und genau an diesem Monitoring Port, den führt man dann einfach raus und sorgt dadurch dafür, dass quasi erst einmal alle Daten an Dollar Dienst gehen. Und der Dienst kümmert sich dann darum, wie er die denn jetzt filtert.
Okay, also der sagen, der wer auch immer da mithört, der kriegt einfach einmal alles.
Und soll selber zusehen, ja.
Und dann kann er sozusagen, dann kann der Telekommunikationsdienst ja gar nicht wissen, wer überwachtet, weil wir werden ja alle überwacht.
Es ist ziemlich perfide, lässt sich aber natürlich, also lässt sich gerade genau in diesem Gesetz auch, lässt sich diese Praxis dann begründen.
Warte mal, reden wir von Deutschland?
Das ist halt die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsverordnung. Dieser sperrige Name wäre wahrscheinlich in den Staaten nicht reüssiert. Da hätten sie sich wahrscheinlich was Knackigeres, mit Terrorismus im Namen bestimmt ausgedacht.
Aber wir waren doch jetzt gerade noch in Amerika. Wie sind wir denn so schnell nach Deutschland gekommen?
Da gibt es verschiedene Gründe. Der eine Grund ist, dass das, was man Lawful Interception nennt, das sind tatsächlich weltweite Standards, die in den Anlagen alle eingebaut sind und die dann nur je nach Gesetzeslage konfiguriert werden.
Da haben sich weltweit die ganzen Telefon-Nerds zusammengesetzt in einer ITU und haben gesagt, wenn die eh alle überwachen wollen, dann gäbe das bestimmt ein heilloses Chaos, wenn die alle mit ihren Büchsen ankommen, die ein eigenes Protokoll sprechen. Also standardisieren wir das mal schön. Dann gibt's da Protokolle, die man als Hersteller von so Equipment dann durch implementieren muss, damit die Überwacher leicht das Spiel haben.
Wir halten mal fest, jede Telekommunikationseinrichtung muss irgendwie eine Überwachungsschnittstelle zur Verfügung stellen, ohne selber zu wissen, welche Daten dabei rausfallen. Das ist mehr oder weniger ein weltweiter Standard. Da frag ich mich doch jetzt, was ist denn an dieser Prism-Sache das Neue?
Das Neue daran ist, dass nicht mehr gezielt, wie gesagt, Lovell Interception ist normalerweise die gezielte Überwachung von Anschlussinhabern, die verdächtigt waren, irgendwelche Straftaten zu tun oder irgendwelche bösen Dinge vorzuhaben. Und worüber wir hier reden, ist, dass alle Leute, die diese Dienste benutzt haben, alle, alle, alle abgehört sozusagen wurden, im Sinne von allen ihre E-Mails, alle ihre Chatprotokolle. Alles, was über die Netze ging, hat sich die NSA gegriffen und das schon über mehrere Jahre unspeichert hat. Und die haben nicht mal vor, das jemand wegzuschmeißen.
Der große Aufschrei war, weil es betrifft Amerikaner.
Warte mal, ich muss noch mal auf den Punkt zurückkommen. Wir haben ja gerade schon geklärt, dass die Lovell Interception, dass die aber so funktioniert, wie Linus es gerade erklärt hat, nämlich da fallen eh erstmal alle Daten raus. Der Punkt war vorher sozusagen, da fallen zwar alle Daten raus. Die Behörden, die da mithören, dürfen aber nur die Daten bestimmter zu überwachender Personen verwenden.
In der Theorie brauchst du dazu dann einen Gerichtsbeschluss, um das zu tun. Wenn du aber eh niemandem Rechenschaft pflichtig bist, wenn der Betreiber das nicht bittet, dann sag mal ja oder nein sozusagen.
Also die Daten sind zwar alle bei dem Dienst angekommen, er durfte sie aber nicht benutzen.
Wer durfte sie nicht benutzen jetzt?
Der Dienst.
Welcher, der deutsche Dienst oder der?
Im deutschen Fall ist das zum Beispiel so, dass die bei, also wir haben einen kleinen Aspekt sowieso die ganze Zeit aus den Vorgelassen, das ist auch bei Prism, dass das Ganze nur gilt für Kommunikation, bei der mindestens ein Kommunikationspartner nicht in den USA ist. Also NSA ist ein Auslandsgeheimdienst für derartige Aufklärung. Aber das Ganze steht und fällt natürlich in dem Moment ineinander zusammen, wo sowieso alles erstmal rausgeblasen wird und dann beim Dienst sortiert wird. Und was sich jetzt eigentlich nur geändert hat, ist das Wissen über das Ausmaß, was da stattfindet. Also dass man sich eigentlich nicht vorstellen konnte, dass die so viel parallele Sortierkraft haben, da kommen ja wirklich sehr, sehr viele Daten, dass sie es schaffen, die so schnell zu sortieren. Und natürlich müssen sie auch eine ganze Menge wegwerfen. Also du willst zum Beispiel nicht den Filesharing-Traffic haben und so. Natürlich haben sie relativ schnelle Vorfilter, um dann dafür zu sorgen, was für sie dann wirklich interessant ist und was nicht. Die können sie aber natürlich die ganze Zeit ändern. Ja, und was quasi jetzt neu ist, für uns ist einfach nur das Ausmaß, in dem das stattfindet und auch gespeichert wird. Noch mal kurz zum deutschen Fall. Das Gesetz sieht glaube ich für den BND vor, dass sie bis zu 20 Prozent dieser grenzüberschreitenden Kommunikationen abgreifen können.
Das heißt, abgreifen können sie alles und sie geben wahrscheinlich auch einmal alles den Amis. Das ist im Moment der Verdacht der Stunde. Aber in der Tat, im Gesetz steht, auswerten dürfen sie nur 20 Prozent die Deutschen.
Na aber, wenn am Ende Geheimdienste aller Länder immer nur die anderen überwachen dürfen und alle Geheimdienste im Rahmen der geheimdienstlichen Zusammenarbeit grenzüberschreitend zusammenarbeiten, dann ist das ein fieser Taschenspielertrick.
Also nochmal, um das, was Erdgeist gerade gesagt hat, nochmal ganz klar zu machen. Also der Geheimdienst eines bestimmten Landes, dem ist nur erlaubt, die Kommunikation zu überwachen, wenn diese ins Ausland unterwegs ist und möglicherweise davon auch nur ein bestimmter Prozentteil.
Wobei die NSL ja auch damit erwischt wurde, inneramerikanische Telefongesellschaften, das fing ja alles sogar vor Prism mit Ferrizon an.
Wenn ich meine Zusammenfassung zusammenfassen könnte.
Lass doch mal kurz den Markus den Punkt halten.
Aber wir müssen dich ja ein bisschen bei der Präzision halten.
Ja, aber die hab ich ja gerade versucht herzustellen. Jetzt bin ich schon wieder ganz durcheinander. Also der Punkt ist, die Dienste bekommen alle Daten und unterteilen sie dann in die Sachen, die sie eigentlich dürfen. Aber vorher schicken sie den anderen Diensten und die dürfen ja dann damit arbeiten.
Die sammeln die im Zweifel auch selber.
Wieso ist die NSA jetzt mit heruntergelassener Hose dabei erwischt worden, dass sie auch Amerikaner spionieren? Was ist da passiert?
Da ist ein ehemaliger Angestellter eines Subkontraktors der als Systemadministrator tätig war. Der hat offenbar nicht nur Zugriff sich verschafft auf die Materialien, die ihm im Rahmen seiner eigenen Aufgaben so über den Tisch liefen, sondern auch alles, wo er technisch Zugriff hatte. Das hat er sich alles schön feinsäulich kopiert. Dann ist er nach Hongkong geflogen und hat angefangen, das Journalisten zu geben.
Also über die Journalisten oder den Journalisten können wir auch gleich genauer sprechen. Wie vertrauenswürdig ist der eigentlich?
Glenn Greenwald?
Nein, nicht der Glenn Greenwald, sondern der Snowman. Wie vertrauenswürdig ist der als Quelle?
Na ja, die Materialien sprechen ja für sich. Also insofern, ich kenne ihn persönlich nicht, aber ich habe bislang den Eindruck, und er hat ja auch in seinem Video, in diesem ursprünglichen Video, eigentlich seine Motivlage sehr plausibel und mit sehr klaren Worten dargestellt. Also ich würde sagen hinreichend vertrauenswürdig.
Okay, dann ist der Glenn Greenwald.
Das ist ein US-amerikanischer Journalist, der für den Guardian die US-Ausgabe arbeitet, der schon vorher mit WikiLeaks zusammengearbeitet hat, dort Geschichten aufbereitet hat. Und der wurde dann von Snowden kontaktiert. Das ging erst schief, weil Greenwald keinen PGP konnte. Und ein halbes Jahr später haben sie es doch geschafft, miteinander in Kontakt zu kommen. Und Ren Linwild hat dann die Kommunikation, die ihm da auf den Tisch gelegt worden ist, schon mal so grob vorgesichtet, in was den meisten Eindruck erst mal macht. Und hat dann jetzt so die, ich glaub, die fünfte Geschichte schon rausgehauen, die er da aus den zusammengesammelten Dokumenten rausgeholt hat.
Wie vertrauenswürdig ist der als journalistischer Bearbeitung der Quelle?
Der ist ein...
Schon sehr lange mit dem Themengebiet vertraut, hat schon sehr lange die Überwachungsinfrastruktur angeprangert und hat sich einen sehr guten Ruf dadurch verschafft, dass er immer extrem glasklar argumentiert.
Und der ist auch Anwalt.
Das ist ja nicht unbedingt was Gutes.
Muss man auch wissen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob deine Erfahrungen der Vertrauenswürdigkeit, ob das hier die richtige Messlatte ist. Es geht ja darum, um die Glaubwürdigkeit, ob hier irgendwie uns hier Lügengeschichten erzählt werden oder ob wir hier auf Basis von nachgewiesenen Fakten. Und das hat sich ja alles, die US-Regierung hat ja die Sachen eingestanden. Es ist bislang überhaupt nicht die Authentizität, das heißt die Echtheit der Dokumente bestritten worden. Es geht jetzt nur um die Frage, wie weitgehend die amerikanische Regierung eigentlich auch ihren eigenen Senat, ihre eigenen Politiker, ihre eigenen Bürger belogen hat, indem sie bestimmte Sachen eben falsch dargestellt haben bislang oder verborgen oder gar nicht dargestellt haben.
Jetzt hast du am Anfang schon gesagt, Prism, mit dem diese Geschichte anfing, ist nur ein kleiner Teil. Wir kommen dann wahrscheinlich auch noch zum britischen Geheimdienst, der noch viel mehr macht. Wer ist da eigentlich ländermäßig noch drin verwickelt?
In dieses spezielle...
In das, was wir jetzt sagen, oder was uns jetzt angetragen wurde an Geschichte?
Zweifel, gibt es eh große Allianzen der Geheimdienste, was man üblicherweise als die westlichen Staaten bezeichnet? Man hat ja schon vor einer Weile angefangen mit dem Echelon-Projekt. Aber ich glaube, da kommen wir nachher noch mal im Detail dazu. Da geht so Neuseeland, Australien, Großbritannien, die USA, Deutschland ist dann wie auch mit dabei so als Zuliefer und bekommt da auch Auswertungen, tauscht dafür.
Also das heißt, wir wissen jetzt konkret gerade nur von den USA und Großbritannien. Aber der Verdacht oder die Erkenntnis aus währigen Geschichten ist sozusagen, dass sie eh alle miteinander reden.
Naja, es gibt ja bei der eine der Veröffentlichungen enthielt ja so eine Heatmap. Das war bei dem Projekt Boundless Informer, also bei dem Abgreifen der internationalen Telekommunikation über die Fasern. Und dort gab es ja so eine Weltkarte, wo der Grad des Abgreifens der Telekommunikation für die verschiedenen Länder dargestellt war und wo interessanterweise Europa als das am best überwachteste Land innerhalb von Europa eben dargestellt war.
Willkommen in Deutschland. Kein ordentliches Internet, aber alles überwacht.
Na, es gibt hier halt juicy Targets. Es gibt ja, wenn man jetzt mal unterstellt, dass die Geheimdienste dort auch schon ihrer lokalen Wirtschaft oder die arme Greifenden, wie sie da gezielt, auch Informationen über Wirtschaftsunternehmen aus Deutschland abgreifenden, gibt es ja hier viele spannende Unternehmen, die man auch schon seit, keine Ahnung, 40 Jahren hier vor Ort belauscht und dann die Informationen ganz dezent weitergibt. Und das begründet dann wohl auch, warum es hier besonders heiß ist. Auch, dass in Deutschland ja auch die vier Besatzermächte schon seit einer Weile ganz offen überwachen durften.
Warum das?
Wir haben so einen Krieg verloren.
Konkret?
Konkret gab es mit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs mehrere Regelungen. Zum einen den sogenannten NATO-Truppenstatut, nach dem die Truppen, die hier in Deutschland stationiert waren, zu ihrem eigenen Schutz, in Anführungszeichen, eigene Abhörbefugnisse hatten, das heißt selbst überwachen gehen konnten. Und zum zweiten gab es sogenannte Verwaltungsvereinbarungen mit den Alliierten, also mit den Franzosen, den Briten, den Amerikanern und den Russen, dass die als Ergänzung, als geheime Zusatzvereinbarung zum G-10-Gesetz die deutschen Nachrichtendienste, namentlich das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und den Bundesnachrichtendienst anweisen konnten bzw. verlangen konnten, dass bestimmte Leute überwacht wurden. Und dann mussten die entsprechenden Nachrichtendienste das sozusagen mit ihren eigenen Mittel, Wegen und juristischen Methoden tun und das dann den Alliierten übergeben. Und beide Vereinbarungen, also sowohl dieses Naht-Truppen-Statut als auch diese sogenannten Verwaltungsvereinbarung, gelten bis heute fort.
Wow, und dann sind wir an dem Punkt, wo wir feststellen, dass ein Skandal, der vor zwei Wochen losging und der vielen von euch möglicherweise vorkam als was? Wir werden alle überwacht. Schon eine sehr, sehr lange Geschichte hat, weil das einfach nur die aktuelle Ausprägung einer Geheimdienstarbeit ist, die möglicherweise so schon länger stattfindet. Wir werden gleich mal einen kleinen Blick in die Historie der Telekommunikationsüberwachung werfen. Vorher gibt es aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Solang es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten auch bei Fritz im Netz.
Also schlüpft euch schon mal in euer Bombast-Röckchen.
Im Fall des ehemaligen Geheimdienstmitarbeiters Snowden verschlechtert sich die Stimmung zwischen den USA und Ecuador. Das südamerikanische Land kündigte ein Zollabkommen mit der Regierung in Washington. Die USA hatten vorher selbst damit gedroht, den Handelsvertrag aufzulösen. Hintergrund ist, dass der amerikanische Ex-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter Snowden Asyl in Ecuador beantragt hat. Die USA wollen ihn vor Gericht stellen, weil er die Abhörprogramme von amerikanischen und britischen Geheimdiensten aufgedeckt hatte. In Brüssel hat der EU-Gipfel zur hohen Jugendarbeitslosigkeit angefangen. Die 27 Staats- und Regierungschefs wollen ein 6 Milliarden Euro schweres Hilfsprogramm auf den Weg bringen. Gut 5, 5 Millionen junge Europäer haben keinen Job. Besonders dramatisch ist die Lage in Krisenländern wie Spanien oder Griechenland. Dort ist mehr als jeder zweite unter 25 Jahren arbeitslos. Deutschland hat strengere EU-Regeln zum Klimaschutz blockiert. Auf Druck der Bundesregierung verschoben die Staats- und Regierungschefs das Abkommen über niedrigere Abgasgrenzwerte nochmal. Es sollte eigentlich heute beschlossen werden. Die Umweltschutzorganisation Greenpeace kritisierte, Bundeskanzlerin Merkel mache Politik für einige wenige Hersteller von Luxusautos. Die Grünen sprachen von einem Skandal. Der Präsident der BTU Cottbus, Zimmerli, wechselt an die Humboldt-Universität Berlin. Ab dem Wintersemester bekommt er eine Senior-Professur, die extra für ihn eingerichtet wird. Er wird sich damit beschäftigen, wie Geistes und Naturwissenschaften stärker zusammenarbeiten können. Zimmerli war sechs Jahre lang Präsident der BTU Cottbus. Wetter Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Steglitz 13, Köpenick 14 Grad, Brandenburg an der Havel, Wiesenburg jeweils 12 Grad und Eberswalde, Lübbenau jeweils 14 Grad. Heute Nacht bleibt es trotz vieler Wolken meistens trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 11 bis 7 Grad runter. Der Tagmorgen fängt dann sonnig an. Im Laufe des Tages sind aber Regen und Gewitter möglich bei maximal 20 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin 100 Stadtring zwischen Tunnel Innsbrucker Platz und Albuinstraße ist in beiden Richtungen die linke Spur wegen einer Baustelle gesperrt. Und 100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding zwischen Hallensee Straße und Dreieck Funkturm ist bis 5 Uhr nur eine Spur befahrbar. Und auch auf der A111-Stadt Autobahnzubringer Uranienburg ist zwischen Weidmannsluster Damm, Hermsdorfer Damm und Schulzendorfer Straße in beiden Richtungen nur eine spurfreie Grundstier eine Baustelle. Zum Verkehr in Brandenburg ab 10 nördlicher Berliner Ringen Richtung Dreieck Schwanenbeck. In Höhe des Dreieck Pankow steht ein kaputter Lasser, dort staut es sich. Ansonsten rollt euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Heute Chaosradio in Blue Moon. Es geht um die Telekommunikationsüberwachung oder das Wort, was ihr vielleicht eher gehört habt. Prism zusammen mit Erdgeist, Andy Müller-Maguhn und Linus Neumann.
Ja und wir haben jetzt gerade schon so ein bisschen zusammengefasst oder wir haben viel erzählt. Ich würde gerne noch mal so kurz zusammenfassen, an welchen Stellen wird jetzt also abgehört? Also es gibt einmal diesen Punkt tatsächlich bei dem Anbieter selber, steht irgendwas, da sind die wahrscheinlich schon beim Bau des Rechenzentrums, stand schon im Architekturplan, stand schon der Schrank, wo dann die Geheimdienste ihre Finger drauf haben. Es gibt dann darüber hinaus die Überwachung bei dem Netzbetreiber und dann geht es noch darauf hinaus in diese tatsächlichen Unterseekabel, wo jetzt die Briten irgendwie dran rumschnorcheln und so. Und da denke ich teilweise, was jetzt gerade auch das Politikum zwischen Deutschland und Großbritannien ist, dieses TRT14-Kabel, die Hauptglasfaser, wo ein Großteil der Kommunikation Westeuropas mit Nordamerika drüber geht.
Das muss man sich wirklich so vorstellen, falls ihr gerade zum ersten Mal von sowas hört. Das Internet ist nicht nur so ein dezentrales Ding, das aus der Wand fällt, sondern tatsächlich irgendwo in Norddeutschland fällt ein dickes Kabel in die Nordsee wahrscheinlich und geht dann rüber zu Großbritannien und dann irgendwann durch den Atlantik rüber in den USA und da setzen die sich drauf.
Da gibt es eine wunderschöne Karte und das sind, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele hundert Untersee-Kabel es gibt. Das ist eine große Menge. Die Briten haben ja, oder im Rahmen dieser Temporal Leaks wurde ja dann bekannt, dass die Briten von sich behaupten, auf 200 davon Zugriff zu haben.
Nur um das Kürze ergänzen, die wunderbare Karte befindet sich unter www.cablemap.info.
Das ist wichtig.
Das ist sozusagen die Karte, wo einfach alle dickeren Internetkabel verzeichnet sind.
Genau, eigentlich alle. Man kann da ganz wunderbar einzelne draufklicken und dann sieht man von wem, also von wo nach wo die gehen, wo die Zwischenstotzen haben, welche Bandbreiten die haben und so fort. Das ist wirklich eine sehr schicke Seite.
Und wenn du jetzt ein Kabel hast wie das THT14 zum Beispiel und die Briten da irgendwie ihren Schnorchel drauf haben und du siehst, dass dieses Kabel mehrere Stationen in Großbritannien betrifft oder mehrere Stationen in Großbritannien macht, das liegt in so einem Ring, dann kannst du dir natürlich vorstellen, dass die Briten sich jetzt nicht die Mühe machen, mit dem U-Boot nach diesem Kabel zu tauchen, sondern im Zweifelsfall einfach direkt an der Betreiberstation selber da ihren Schnorchel dranhalten.
Oder die Meinung noch auseinandergehen. Ich würde einfach sagen, die machen das Bock, just because we can. Ist das nicht cool mit dem U-Boot? Ja, müssen wir, nee, müssen wir nicht, aber lass mal.
Wir haben also das U-Boot und wir haben den Raum beim Telekommunikationsanbieter oder wo das Kabel durchläuft. Gibt es noch andere technische Dinge, die man da macht?
Jede Menge. Es gibt ja noch Satellitenübertragungen beispielsweise, die ebenfalls relativ einfach von verschiedenen Standorten eingesammelt und dann wiederum zur Sammlung hinzugefügt werden kann. Und es gibt natürlich auch, um inländische Kommunikation abzugreifen, hier und da Vereinbarungen mit Service-Providern oder eben mit den Regierungen der jeweiligen Ländern, wo dann auch noch mal großflächig abgegriffen wird und das wiederum dann in diese zentralen Einsammlungspunkte übergeben wird.
Da kann man auch präzise werden. Bei den Internet-Exchange-Punkten, wo da so alle Provider, ihre Server und vor allem Router in den Rack schieben, da gibt es auch einfach Vereinbarungen, dass da inländische Bedarfsträger da auch einfach noch mal in die Racks ihre eigene DPI-Hardware reintun.
Jetzt DPI heißt Deep Pack Inspection? Das ist also sagen, die Technik, die dafür benutzt wird, um sozusagen so einen Internet-Datenfluss ganz bis aufs kleinste Detail auseinanderzunehmen, halt bis ins letzte Paket. Jetzt haben wir aber an dieser Stelle nur von den Infrastrukturanbietern geredet, also sagen den Leuten, die das Internet tatsächlich möglich machen. Jetzt ist ja in dieser ersten Prism-Sache kamen ja, also fliehen ja Namen wie Apple, wie Microsoft, wie Yahoo. Wie ist das da? Wie wird das da überwacht? Setzen sie sich dann auch irgendwie bei Yahoo in die Konzernzentrale oder, man hat doch auch irgendwas gehört, von einem geheimen Zugang, den die da zu dem System irgendwie kriegen? Also so eine Art Extra-Portal, wo man sich einloggt und alles runterlädt?
Es ist bis heute doch etwa strittig. Zumindest Google hat das vehement bestritten. Facebook hat auch, wenn auch nicht genau so eindeutig, aber eigentlich gesagt, dass es sowas nicht gibt. Und die haben beide darauf erwiesen, dass es natürlich für einzelne, das einzelne Abgreifen von Kommunikation durch, wenn da Straftäter kommunizieren und so fort, dass es da Mittel und Wege gibt. Aber dass es eben keine geheime Generalzugangsgeschichte gibt. Das würde sich aber dadurch erklären, dass möglicherweise an den sozusagen Übergabepunkten, wo also die Facebooks, Googles und so dieser Welt, wo die ihre Server stehen haben, wenn dort auch wiederum Überwachungseinrichtungen stehen, die eben automatisch abgreifen und rausfiltern, dann muss man gar nicht die Einzelnen verpflichten, sondern man nimmt das einfach da, wo die ihren Internetanschluss sozusagen haben, beziehungsweise ihre diversen Anschlüsse.
Das heißt, das ist schon glaubwürdig, wenn die großen Firmen sagen, wir haben damit überhaupt gar nichts zu tun.
Na ganz überhaupt können sie es ja nicht leugnen, denn zusätzlich gibt es ja noch diesen Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act, ein schönes US-Gesetz aus dem Jahr 1978, in dem das Wort Foreign kommt, das stront schon drin vor, das heißt, da geht es um diese Auslandskommunikation. Und da können also dann Anträge gestellt werden. Wir hätten jetzt gerne einmal alle E-Mails von Person X, und da gibt es ein eigenes Gericht für, der US Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Court. Und wenn man dem einen Antrag stellt und sagt, wir möchten gerne die Daten von diese und jene Daten haben, dann macht er da ein Stempel drauf und dann ist das ein Richterbeschluss. Und dann hat der jeweilige Diensteanbieter, also Facebook oder was auch immer, dem Folge zu leisten. Und da gab es ja jetzt auch im Rahmen dieser Debatte die größere Ankündigung von Google, da mehr Transparenz reinzubringen, wie viele von diesen Anfragen sie bekommen.
Und da war doch auch dann irgendwie die Rede davon, dass sie das gar nicht dürfen.
Genau. Sie müssen diese Daten rausrücken, dürfen aber niemandem davon erzählen und dürfen auch nicht dagegen klagen, weil dann hätten sie ja jemandem davon erzählt. Na das ist ja eine alte Geschichte, das kennen wir ja schon von dem Gerichtsverfahren, was Rob Gong greibt, Birgitta Jonsdottir, Jack Applebaum geführt haben, wegen eines solchen Requests auf ihre Daten bei Twitter. Und Twitter hat dann irgendwie dagegen geklagt und hat dann diesen Request öffentlich gemacht und dann konnten die betroffenen Personen, die also alle samt zu einem Zeitpunkt mal mit WikiLeaks in Kontakt standen, sich dann irgendwie gerichtlich dagegen wehren, dass diese Daten rausgegeben würden.
Das hört sich alles sehr geheimnisgremerisch und nicht so doll demokratisch an. Also dieses Gericht, von dem du gerade erzählt hast, der FISA, ist das denn sozusagen wie so ein Gericht, wo man hingehen kann und sagen kann, so hier, ich will jetzt auch mal eine Anklage machen oder ist das auch...
Das ist ein geheimtagendes Gremium, in dem die Anträge auf Überwachung vorgelegt werden und wo sich jetzt herausgestellt hat, die letztjährige Statistik sah so aus, dass 1789 Anträge gestellt wurden und 1789 Anträge genehmigt wurden. Das heißt, man hat nicht den Eindruck, dass es ein normales Gericht ist, das irgendwie Faktenprüf und auch mal Nein sagt, sondern die winken durch.
Und geheimtagen heißt, man kann diese Beschlüsse auch nirgends so nachlesen?
Das würde ja... Man kann auch die Entscheidungsfällen auch nicht öffentlich. Das heißt, du hast normalerweise nicht mal Kenntnis davon, dass es einen solchen Beschluss gegeben hat, es sei denn, du bist unmittelbar betroffen. Da steht halt nur, das Gericht hat beschlossen und du musst jetzt machen.
Das ist eine Stempelbude.
Ja, aber war das mit der Demokratie nicht so, dass sich die drei Säulen gegenseitig überwachen sollen? So eine Scherze.
Ja, aber doch nicht. Also Geheimdienst ist ja der Geheimdienst wacht über der Demokratie.
Dafür gibt es ja dann auch parlamentarische Kontrollgremien, an die man sich dann im Zweifel...
Da gab es doch in Deutschland... Lass mal nochmal ein Visabell. Gibt es für dieses NSA-FISA-Konglomerat, gibt es da ein parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium?
Offiziell glaube ich schon, ja. Und dann die hätte sich ja auch Snowden wenden sollen, laut der Kommentatoren, um den demokratischen Rechtsweg da beizubehalten.
Okay, also das ist aber trotzdem, dass alles total geheim ist. Und mir zumindest ein bisschen komisch vorgekommen, ist das alles legal?
Ja, das war ja der größte Ärger, den da so großer Aufschrei in den USA am Ende sogar auch US-Amerikaner mit überwacht und dann sagen, das war nicht mit Absicht. Wir wussten ja auch nicht, weil die Algorithmen, um rauszufinden, wer denn jetzt wirklich Amerikaner ist, war so, wir haben immer so geguckt und wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit bei 51 Prozent liegt, dann haben wir das einfach überwacht, also dass es kein Amerikaner ist.
Das ist geil, 51 Prozent. Also es ist ungefähr bei 100 Münzwürfen.
Plötzlich macht es dann auch Sinn, warum Facebook einem dann immer ganz schlimm nach seiner Telefonnummer fragt und wie, in welcher Stadt man denn wohnt und so. Und plötzlich macht das alles Sinn. Da will man eigentlich sagen, dass man US-Amerikaner sei und sonst wo wohnt und da vielleicht noch eine plausible Telefonnummer eintragen, damit man zumindest rein juristisch nicht von den Geheimdiensten der USA überwacht wird.
Aber wenn da ein Prozent Zweifel besteht an deiner Hand.
Aber bringt de facto gar nichts. Also wer das bei der nächsten Fritz-Werbe-Pause hier nochmal sich grafisch angucken möchte, mal kurz auf bugplanet.info gehen, dort in die Suchmache US eingeben. Und da gibt es ganz unten einen Link auf ein Video. Das ist so zwei Minuten lang, dass das kurz nochmal illustriert, wie diese Gerichtsentscheidungen fällen und wie die Prozedur läuft.
Okay, haben wir gerade eine kleine Hörermeldung bekommen, dass wir immer international, beispielsweise ausländische Sicherheitsdienst zur NSA sagen. Also was genau ist die NSA nochmal?
Der Auslandsüberwachungs- oder nein, überhaupt der Telekommunikationsüberwachungsdienst der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika.
Der aber ins Ausland gerichtet ist?
Nee, der ist eben auch seit einiger Zeit ins Inland gerichtet. Die Storch war das mal. Er heißt ja National Security Agency. Und National ist ja nicht international, sondern...
Aber seit es das Problem mit dem Domestic Terror gab und dort der Wiener 11 nicht im Vorfeld erkannt worden ist, haben sie da auch dann noch die Befugnisse deutlich ausgeweitet.
Du hast bei den Geheimdiensten üblicherweise so einen, der sagt, wir gucken, was von außen kommt und sorgen dadurch für die innere Sicherheit. Und dann hast du noch einen Geheimdienst, der nach innen schaut und sagt, wir gucken, dass uns von innen hier keiner irgendwie...
Ich dachte immer, das wären CIA und NSA.
Die USA haben ja noch sehr viel mehr Geheimdienste. Die krieg ich, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr auf eine. Da bin ich nicht der Experte für.
Jetzt haben wir also geklärt, was abgeschnorchelt wird, wo das abgeschnorchelt wird, dass das ganz legal abgeschnorchelt wird. Was ich mich jetzt gerade frage ist, wer genau macht das denn? Also jetzt hieß es ja irgendwie der Snowden, also der Leaker, der hat ja nicht bei der NSA gearbeitet, sondern bei einem sogenannten Subcontractor.
Das macht da nicht so viel Unterschied. Es gab da irgendwie, ich weiß nicht.
Das macht schon einen Unterschied.
Die haben da irgendwie bei der NSA das sehr bewusst gemacht, dass da vor drei Jahren die Hälfte der Techniker bei der NSA rausgeworfen wurde und am nächsten Tag mit neuen Badges wieder bei der NSA dann als Subunternehmer reingelaufen sind. Es findet eine große Industrialisierung der... Richtig, Entschuldigung, die Privatisierung der Überwachungsinfrastruktur statt so wie auch in vielen anderen Bereichen dort...
Es gibt ja auch wie diese Blackwaters zum Beispiel diese Private Military Contractor und genauso gibt es halt das, was man Private Intelligence Contractors nennt, wo halt die Argumentation ist, dass die Privatwirtschaft ja viel effektiver agiert, als es so Behörden und Regierungsapparate tun. Und entsprechend kann man denen ja mehr Geld bezahlen. De facto gibt es aber das, was man in Amerika die Revolving Dawn nennt, also eine Drehtür, wo dauernd Leute auch in hohen Positionen zwischen den hohen nachrichtendienstlichen Positionen und der Geschäftsführung bzw. den Gesellschaftsstrukturen dieser Privatunternehmen hin und her wechseln.
Ich halte mal fest, wir haben eine totale Telekommunikationsüberwachung, die von einem geheimen, nicht öffentlich demokratisch legitimierten Ding gesteuert wird und das wird aber nicht von einem staatlich betriebenen Geheimdienst durchgeführt, sondern von einem Subunternehmen, das dieser Geheimdienst angestellt hat.
Naja, in diesem Fall war es ja so, dass der Subkontraktor halt in einer Station, die schon offiziell eine NSA-Station ist, da Analysten unterhält und teilweise auch technische Strukturen betreibt. Also das vermischt sich ein bisschen.
Aber ist es nicht, also ist es sozusagen, du sagst das so, als ob das was ganz Normales wäre. Ist das nicht so ein bisschen komisch, wenn also...
Na, ja, natürlich ist es komisch. Aber so kleines Beispiel hier aus Deutschland, wenn irgendjemand aus irgendeinem Grund bei dir zu Hause einmarschiert, also irgendjemand jetzt nicht, aber wenn die Polizei bei dir zu Hause einmarschiert und deine Festplatten beschlagnahmt zur Auswertung, dann werden die ja auch nicht im Normalfall von irgendwelchen Technikern des BKA oder LKA ausgewertet, sondern zu vertrauenswürdigen, wahrscheinlich sicherheitsüberprüften Dritten, die da die Nerds im Keller halten, weitergegeben und die kratzen dann auf der Platte rum und suchen dann und geben dann zweifelspannende Informationen raus und wenn die klicken, sind sie halt ein bisschen in dein Privatordner rum. Weiß man ja alles nicht. Also es ist auch in Deutschland jetzt nichts Neues. Und in den Staaten ist es halt genauso, dass man dann einfach unterschreibt, da tut man das und das und das nicht. Und die Firma, bei der der Snowden gearbeitet hat, die hat ja auch am Ende gesagt, das ist eigentlich mit unserem Code of Conduct nicht vereinbar, was der da gemacht hat, nämlich irgendwie die Informationen von unserem Kunden, was dann irgendwie die NSA ist, dort jetzt in die Öffentlichkeit zu geben. Das fanden die scheiße und haben den auch erst mal abgemahnt.
Ah ja, das ist wieder einer der frustrierenderen Chaosradios, die ich gerade hier mitmache, weil es so ein bisschen desillusioniert. Okay, es gibt sozusagen so eine Schattenwirtschaft, eine Schattenwelt, die uns alle komplett überwacht. Okay, haben wir jetzt geklärt.
Die haben alle ganz herrlich selbst in die Tasche wirtschaften. Weil das Tolle bei diesen halb privaten Strukturen ist ja auch noch, dass das alles unter Geheimhaltung ist, d.h. sowas wie Korruption oder Überberechnung.
Nein, die Geheimhaltung ist nur, damit der Terrorist nicht weiß, was wir vorhaben.
Also ich halte, also sage, die Budgets sind also auch geheim.
Also der BND zum Beispiel, der wollte jetzt mal schnell 100 Millionen haben. Da kann man schon, vielleicht stellen die dann endlich mal Personal ein, das was drauf hat.
Ja gut, also der kann man vielleicht noch ganz kurz erzählen, dass der BND im, ich glaube, der letzte Bericht des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgehebens, geht ja glaube ich um 2011, da haben sie ja 290 Millionen E-Mails, SMS und so weiter analysiert.
Oh ja, das war zu viel, ne?
Und sind da ein bisschen an ihre Grenzen gestoßen, weil sie ihre, sie sind des Spams nicht hergeworden. Also der BND, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das einfach auch dazu gehört, irgendwie seine eigenen Fähigkeiten im eigenen Land ein bisschen runterzuspielen. Aber die scheinen sich da im Moment noch ein bisschen ungeschickt angestellt zu haben, zumindest vor ein paar Jahren und wollen deshalb natürlich jetzt mehr stellen. Sie wollen, glaube ich, was waren das, 100 oder 500 Personen anstellen und natürlich auch neue Hardware kaufen. Denn mit diesen 290 Millionen E-Mails waren sie ja bei weitem noch nicht an dem rechtlich zulässigen Maximum von 20 Prozent. Das heißt, sie bleiben hinter ihren rechtlichen Kompetenzen zurück. Und immerhin haben sie ja in diesem Jahr 290 relevante E-Mails gefiltert.
290.000?
Nein, 290 sind am Ende im Filter hängen geblieben.
Du bist dir sicher, dass da keine Nullen fehlen?
Nein, 290 waren relevant.
Wie viel hat das gekostet?
Den Preis hab ich jetzt gerade nicht im Kopf. Du bist ja auch ein Rattenschwanz an Jahren dran, was man da als Geld für ausgegeben hat.
Aber wo wir gerade dabei sind, es gibt also ganz viele Daten, die anfallen und möglicherweise stellen sich da andere Agenturen cleverer an als die bei uns. Aber egal, wie genau wird denn dieses ganze Zeug analysiert? Also nach welchen Kriterien? Ihr habt ja jetzt schon ganz grob gesagt, also es gibt irgendwie dieser Würfel, der entscheidet, ob man jetzt Amerikaner ist oder nicht, also ob man überwachtet oder nicht. Und dann kann ich sagen, gibt es einfache Möglichkeiten, um so was wie File Sharing Traffic rauszuwerfen. Aber dann hat man diese ganzen Daten von ganz vielen Personen. Wie wird daraus dann etwas gemacht, was ein Geheimdienst oder ein Mensch oder ein Analyst überhaupt verwenden kann?
Ich glaube, wir hatten hier vor Ort zwei oder drei Sendungen, da hat man den Joscha zu Besuch gehabt, der mal so ein bisschen was über Expertensysteme und künstliche Intelligenz und die ganze Technologie dahinter erzählt hat, wo er auch ein bisschen frustriert erzählt hat, dass es immer so ein Flavor of the Day in der KI-Forschung gab, der dann plötzlich mit Drittmitteln beworfen worden ist. Und diese Expertensysteme, da kamen plötzlich aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen ganz viel Geld, was draufgeworfen worden ist. Und da wurde eigentlich das Data Mining, was heutzutage sowohl in der Privatwirtschaft benutzt wird, also von Facebook, meine Facebook ist ja eigentlich auch nur ein Geheimdienst. Und blubbert jetzt wahrscheinlich rum, dass andere Geheimdienste auch an ihre Daten ranwollen, ohne zu bezahlen oder so. Und Facebook macht da ja auch nichts anderes, als diese ganzen Algorithmen drüber laufen zu lassen, um dann wie für dich relevante Informationen dir zu kredenzen. Und Google macht das ja auch. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass wir mit riesigen Datenmengen...
Na ja, gut, aber Google und Facebook, wenn die über unsere persönlichen Daten drüber gehen, dann habe ich ein sehr klares Bild davon, was die wollen. Die wollen mich einsortieren in eine Schublade, wo drauf steht, ist 20 Jahre alt, hat 5 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung und kauft gerne lila Seife. Deswegen präsentieren wir jetzt lila Seife-Werbung.
Er setzt das mal durch, ist 20 Jahre alt, ist irgendwie arabischstämmig und keine Ahnung, irgendwie ist lang baut und...
Fingert die Regierung doof.
Und hat irgendwie gerade in irgendeinem Landwirtschaftsmarkt größere Mengen Salpetersäure gebraucht, so bing, bing, bing, bing, bing. Also was da irgendwie Google tut, was Facebook tut und was dann die Geheimdienste davon ihren Daten wollen, ist da eigentlich nur...
Aber das Tolle ist, du kannst ihm auch die Salpetersäure werben. Andere anderen, das heißt, du kannst die Terroristen züchten. Du musst noch mal die Vorteile sehen.
Kunden, die die Salpetersäure gekauft haben, haben auch Wecker gekauft.
Kunden, die diesen Artikel laden, kaufen.
Aber ist das wirklich alles?
Aber ich wollte nur mal ganz kurz, man hört ja immer ziemlich oft, wer soll denn das alles lesen? Das kann man ja irgendwie eh nicht alles filtern. Und wer soll sich denn für das interessieren, was ich da tue? Aber in Wirklichkeit ist einfach große Datenbank. Du tust da alles rein und lässt da irgendwie mal gern köcheln. Und wenn du das genug korrelierst, dann irgendwann sind auch langweilige Personen mal spannend und irgendwann sind plötzlich ehemals langweilige Aktionen rücken dann in den komischen Fokus, wo irgendwas, was du in deiner Jugend getan hast, plötzlich...
Also, Elclag hat das Ganze ja die United Stasi auf Amerika genannt. Weil in dem Moment, wo du wirklich eine Vollüberwachung der Bevölkerung hast, kannst du ja über Kompromate, das heißt über Erpressungsmaterialien und in einer prüden Gesellschaft in Amerika, ist das relativ einfach. Oder aber über irgendwelche begünstigenden Faktoren an jede beliebige Person rangehen. Und zwar nicht unbedingt über die Person direkt, sondern über ihr Umfeld. Weil du siehst ja das, was die den sozialen Grafen nennen. Also durch die Auswärts- und der Verkehrsdaten oder auch der Verbindungsdaten sehen sie ja, wer mit wem in Kommunikation steht und auch in was für einer Art von Beziehung, ob die beruflich, privater Natur ist, irgendwelche Themen es da geht und so fort. Und entsprechend können sie eigentlich beliebig sich an Personen, wie sie sagen, heranspielen. Das ist so ein nachendienstlicher Ausdruck für strategische und taktische Spielchen, wo man dann eben eine Person zu irgendwelche Leute heranführt, irgendwelche Ideen gibt, ihnen genauso wie die Marketingwirtschaft, das bei den sozialen Netzen macht, ihnen eben irgendwelche Produkte oder Dienstleistungen aus kommerziellen Gründen reindrückt, eben aus Kontrollinteressen irgendwelche politischen Maßnahmen nahelegt.
Vielleicht bleiben wir nochmal ganz kurz bei dem technischen Teil, also diesem Big Data. Also was ich eigentlich haben möchte, ich will natürlich so viele Daten wie möglich haben, man möchte die natürlich in irgendeiner Form für mich aggregieren und aufbereiten. Also es kommt da alles rein und ich sehe jetzt zum Beispiel, wer mit wem kommuniziert. Das ist schon mal eine sehr schöne Sache. Was aber spannender ist, sind dann so Profile zu bilden. Und die kannst du natürlich nach jedem einzelnen Kriterium machen. Und spannend wird es dann, wenn du diese Kriterien bei mehreren Personen feststellst. Also so etwas wie kauft dieses und jenes in einem Online-Shop, finde ich da noch fast ein viel zu kleines Merkmal. Denk mal eher an sowas wie Schlafwachrhythmus, wann holt der denn seine E-Mails ab, was hat der für ein Einkommen, wie kommuniziert der mit Menschen, kommuniziert der verschlüsselt oder nicht, solche Dinge. Du kannst halt Unmengen dieser Merkmale für alle möglichen Personen setzen. Und die schiere Menge, Gesetz der großen Zahl, erlaubt es dir dann eben Zusammenhänge festzustellen und beliebige Profile zu definieren. Und die entstehen natürlich dann auch ganz automatisch. Die automatisch entstehenden Profile sind das, was Google interessiert. Ich habe am Ende dann 5, 6 Profile, die auf meine Person passen. Und dann probiere ich einfach durch und kann ja auch immer verifizieren mit meiner Werbung. Ich gebe dem dann irgendwie die Werbung, dann klickt er drauf. Gibt ihm die Werbung, klickt er nicht drauf. Und so steigt mein Wissen konstant an. Ohne, und da ist dann das Schöne an der Technik oder an den Analyseverfahren, die kann ich nämlich derart gestalten, dass sie nicht quasi gezielt eine, wie der Fehler, den der Mensch macht, der Fehler, den der Mensch macht, ist, er hat irgendwie eine Hypothese über diesen Menschen und will die dann eventuell bestätigt sehen. Diese technischen Systeme prüfen aber randommäßig einfach immer Hypothesen und bilden ihre Hypothesen auf den Daten. Und für die gibt es nichts.
Aha, okay, also die, kurz für mein Verständnis zu wiederholen. Es ist also nicht so, dass sozusagen ein Rechensystem entworfen wird, wo man von vornherein irgendwie Verdachtsmerkmale reingibt und dann fallen Verdächtige raus, sondern man sagt dem Computer, rechne doch mal über all diese Daten und guck mal, was du für Zusammenhänge findest.
Genau.
Und dann guck mal nach Patterns. Das Problem dabei ist aber beendet, dass man nur noch Korrelationen findet, wo man nicht mehr weiß, wo die herkommen. Also es ist nicht mehr so, dass du deine Theorie hast, was dort der Grund ist, dass du diese Muster da siehst, sondern du siehst nur diese Muster und würdest dann im Zweifel einfach dagegen agieren. Du kannst ja, es gibt damals mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, haben wir gezeigt, dass wenn du die Metadaten der Kommunikation daher nimmst, reicht ja meistens auch, lassen sich ganz effizient verwursten.
Also Metadaten, alles, was bei der Kommunikation anfällt, außer der eigentliche Inhalt.
Also wer, mit wem, wann, wo, wie lange. Und vor allem noch in welcher zeitlichen Reihenfolge. Und das ist ja standardmäßig, hier kann man das ja benutzen, um so Netzwerke von Personen zu mappen, um dann zu zeigen, wer da so die Keyplayer sind. Und am Ende brauchst du dann, wenn du zum Beispiel, jetzt mal grad nicht die USA, aber wenn du irgendwo die Redelsführer in deinem kleinen Schurkenstarten da alle mal ausfindig machen möchtest, ist dir am Ende total egal. Du willst kein Gerichtsverfahren, du willst es niemandem beweisen, sondern du machst einfach Rakete auf, irgendwie alle, die dort viele Connections haben in dem Grafen. Und dann hast du da mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit eine...
Die Meldung kam gerade heute raus, dass die USA angeblich diese Drohnentötung nicht auf bestimmte Leute angesetzt haben, deren Namen sie kannte, sondern dass die einfach nur gesagt haben, ja, hier, verdächtiges Gebäude, da ist jemand rausgekommen, schießt den mal ab. Also das ist sozusagen die Horrorversion. Die andere Horrorversion, die man hat bei diesem System, ist ja, wenn man erst mal angefangen hat, Muster zu erkennen, dann will man möglicherweise nicht nur die Leute festnehmen oder beeinflussen, die einen Verbrechen begangen haben, sondern stellt dann fest, okay, nach dem und dem Muster sind Leute aus dieser Kategorie welche, die dieses Verbrechen mal begehen werden. Also ja, Minority Report, Pre-Crime. Kennt ihr, gibt es da irgendwie so Bestrebungen in der Richtung, dass man sagt, wir versuchen voraus zu sagen, wer Verbrechen begeht und wir beobachten den?
Das ergibt sich ja automatisch. Das System läuft ja über Jahre. Das heißt, je mehr du da reinfütterst, wird er dir die Sachen irgendwann finden.
Aber du scheinst noch mit der naiven Annahme zu unterliegen, dass es hier um Verbrechensbekämpfung geht. Nachrichtendienste sind nicht in der Verbrechensbekämpfung tätig. Nachrichtendienste unterliegen nicht mal dem Legalitätsprinzip, sondern dem sogenannten Opportunitätsprinzip. Das heißt, die können auch Straftaten begehen, die können auch Leute zu Straftaten anleiten. Alles nur im Interesse des Staates. Also des Staatsapparats, sollte man vielleicht präzise sagen, aber im Staat könnte man auf die Idee kommen, das sind ja wir.
Haben da nicht irgendwie die Briten dieses Problem gehabt, dass da die Baumschützer dort unterwandert worden sind von so ein paar Argenv-Provokateurs, die dort irgendwie auch noch die Frauen da geschwängert haben und danach abgehauen sind und dort selber fiese, aufrührerische Briefe geschrieben haben und selber um die Bewegung dort in Diskredit zu bringen, zu, naja, man kann sagen, terroristischen Aktionen aufgewiegelt haben. Also wenn du da erstmal im Schutze der Geheimhaltung aus Terror-Schutzgründen bist, dann hast du natürlich ein mächtiges Werkzeug in der Hand, sowohl Inkompetenz als auch Korruption als auch ganz andere Motive noch zu kaschieren.
So.
Nochmal zurück zu meiner eigentlichen Frage.
Ach, die ignorieren wir doch sowieso.
Ja, ich weiß. Deswegen will ich sie nochmal stellen, damit sie weiter ignorieren kann. Dieses sozusagen die Vorhersage, also die Idee, jemanden aus dem Verkehr zu ziehen, der vorher überhaupt einen Verbrechen begangen hat, weil er es möglicherweise könnte, laut der statistischen Voraussage aus dem Algorithmus. Wird sowas, weiß man, ob sowas...
Nein, es gibt irgendwie dieses Projekt Gegenwirken, zum Beispiel in Holland, ist ja genauso angelegt, dass du hast da irgendjemand, da hast du so ein schlechtes Gefühl bei dem. Und da fängt man dann an, so die Lotterie der alltäglichen Beschwerden, die so ein Staat seinen Bürgern aufverlegen kann, so eine Steuertiefenprüfung, da kommt das Gesundheitsamt vorbei, dann kommt mal die Feuerwehr bei dir zu Hause vorbei und identifiziert einfach so potenzielle Störenfriede und kann dann einfach schon, ohne jetzt die Leute wirklich zu belangen strafrechtlich, kann sie ihnen mal so viel Sand ins Getriebe schmieren, um sie ein bisschen weniger anstrengend zu machen und sie so zu normieren.
Woher kommt das? Nach welchen Kriterien wird dieses Ding ausgelöst, von dem du gerade erzählst?
Na, man kann ja irgendwie eine Glockenkurve errechnen, was sowieso Standardverhalten ist, und alle, die links und rechts abweichen, sind irgendwie schon mal verdächtig.
Genau das ist der wichtige Punkt. Du willst also auf N-Dimensionen Normalverhalten definieren und dann quasi auch wissen, was ist normale Abweichung von dem Normalverhalten? Dann hast du irgendwann so deine Gruppenprofile und so. Und dann willst du quasi die paar Personen oder den geringen Anteil an Personen, die so völlig untypisch verhalten. Die willst du dir dann mal rausschauen. Und da brauchst du dann am Ende wieder den Menschen, der vielleicht anfängt, ein bisschen rumzuteoritisieren.
Also im Detail gibt es diesbezüglich eine eigene Industrie. Das nennt sich Intelligence Support Systems. Und was die machen, sind tatsächlich aus den Reihen Verkehrsdaten, wer mit wem, aber auch mit zusammenhängenden Daten. Also es werden auch Finanzströme, personelle Bewegungsprofile und ähnliche Sachen zusammen ausgewertet. Und da werden dann so Muster angelegt, automatisiert, wo du quasi Organigramme hast. Das heißt, du weißt, so sieht eine Firma mit Angestellten und Niederlassung aus, so sieht ein Drogenhändler aus, der irgendwie einen Supplier hat, also jemand, von dem er das Zeug bezieht und Kunden hat, an die er es weitergibt. Da gibt es bestimmte Muster, mit denen solche Kommunikation in verschiedenen Branchen abläuft. Und dann kannst du, wenn du diese Muster hast, nach den Mustern suchen. Das heißt, du gehst einfach, dazu ist dann so Vorratdatenspeicherung toll. Das heißt, du hast mal die komplette Kommunikationsverhaltensdatenbank deiner Bevölkerung und dann kannst du sagen, wer macht dann hier was? Und kannst, ohne dass du jetzt jemanden Einzelnen weißt oder einen Anhaltspunkt hast, dass dir irgendwas verdächtig ist, kannst du sagen, na das sieht doch hier genauso aus, wie der Fall, den wir neulich hatten, wo jemand irgendwie Drogen gehandelt hat oder was auch immer getan hat. Und kannst diese Daten dann nutzen. Aber das bezieht sich natürlich genauso auf politische Aktivitäten und nicht nur auf irgendwelche Straftaten. Und nochmal, du musst immer sehen, wir reden hier nicht von Strafverfolgungsbehörden, wir reden hier nicht von der Polizei, sondern wir reden von Nachrichtendiensten. Die haben eine andere und eigene Agenda.
Aber welche denn kennen wir vielleicht gleich? Heute Chaos Radio in Blue Moon und wir beschäftigen uns mit den großen Brüdern mit Details der Telekommunikationsüberwachung, mit dem Überwachungsskandal, der in den letzten Wochen aufgedeckt wurde, indem wir mal ein bisschen in Detail auf den Zahn fühlen wollen. Es ist nichts Schönes, was man hier lernt, weil man lernt hier, dass es sozusagen technische Systeme gibt, die dafür geeignet sind, alle Daten, die bei der Telekommunikation, also egal ob Telefon oder Internet anfallen, einfach mal abzugreifen und mitzunehmen. Und wir lernen auch, dass darauf große Software geworfen werden, die dann so eine Art Normalmenschen ausrechnen. Und diese Normalmenschen, die sind gut und alle, die so ein bisschen unnormal sind, die sind schlecht und werden möglicherweise dann irgendwie mal noch mal gesondert überwacht oder vielleicht mal rausgezogen. Und das ist auch total legal, weil es gibt Gesetze, die es erlauben, die möglicherweise auch sehr alt sind. Und B ist es total geheim. Das heißt, niemand, der außerhalb dieses Geheimdienst möglicherweise so ein bisschen parlamentarisch, was damit zu tun hat, weiß überhaupt, was da genau passiert. So jetzt hat Andy schon mehrfach gesagt, die Geheimdienste sind ja, weil man die naive Vorstellung vielleicht hat, dass es ja da, also im Prinzip wird ja mal gesagt, es gibt Sicherheit, Verbrechen, Terrorismus etc. Geheimdienste haben eine eigene Agenda. Aber welche Agenda haben die denn?
Das ist eine relativ weitläufige Frage. Ich meine, wenn du dir Länder wie Ägypten anguckst oder Bahrain oder Oman oder so, das ist relativ offensichtig. Die Agenda der Nachhindienste ist, den Staatsapparat oder die jeweiligen Machtstrukturen zu stärken und jede Opposition, jede Bewegung, die darauf abzielt, Macht dezentraler zu verteilen und von dem zentralen Machtzyklus weg hin zu irgendwelchen anderen Leuten hin zu verteilen, zu unterbinden. Und jetzt könnte man nur auf die Idee kommen, dass das vielleicht in allen Ländern fast dasselbe ist. Weil dieser Beamtenapparat, der diese Angelegenheiten betreibt, der hat ja auch Selbsterhaltungstriebe. Der ist ja nicht nur dazu da, um irgendwie das Grundgesetz herunterzubeten, sondern die wollen auch alle gerne schöne, dicke Autos fahren und ordentliches Geld verdienen und so weiter und so fort. Und da kommen wir dann auch, ich meine, wenn man sich dann noch diese Privatisierungsgeschichten in den USA anguckt, das ist noch mal doppelt krass. Aber selbst hier in Deutschland könnte man ja auf die Idee kommen, brauchen wir das eigentlich noch so nach dem NS-Kaltenkrieg ist und so fort? Also wer schützt uns da eigentlich vor wem? Und jetzt könnten wir noch über NSU oder sonst was reden, ob der Verfassungsschutz wirklich die Verfassung schützt. Das ist dann so wie ob Zitronenfalter auf Zitronen falten. Aber da stellen sich eine Menge Fragen, die man so pauschal erst mal nicht beantworten kann. Sondern man kann das nur so strukturell analysieren. Und nun, jetzt hätten wir noch auf der Agenda darüber zu reden, wie sich die Technologien eigentlich entwickelt hat. Weil eine der Dinge, die bis vor wenigen Jahren noch so als unvorstellbar galt, war ja tatsächlich alles aufzuzeichnen. Also man muss ja auch mal ein bisschen darüber reden, was da technisch passiert ist. Nicht nur das Internet ist besser geworden, sondern Speicherplatz ist zum Beispiel viel billiger geworden. Festplatten, Storage, wie man es nennt. Und es haben sich da, ich sag mal, die Möglichkeiten auch verändert. Und es hat sich eine eigene Industrie gebildet, die eigentlich nichts anderes tut als Überwachungstechnologie, eben Auswertungstechnologie, Aufzeichnung und so fort anzubieten. Und die in so einer Art machiavellischen Diensteifrigkeit sehr eigene Ausstellungen haben. Diese Ausstellung nennt sich, ist so eine Wanda-Ausstellung sozusagen, Intelligent Support, setzt uns eben. Und die gehen nach dem Motto so vor, können wir ihnen nicht helfen, ihre Bevölkerung so ein bisschen effektiver zu überwachen, zu unterdrücken, zu kontrollieren. Und damit sind die relativ erfolgreich. Das findet einmal im Jahr in Dubai statt. Dann gibt es das Ganze in Prag und nochmal in Mexiko. Und in Dubai, das ist eben die größte Ausstellung. Da sind halt die ganzen arabischen Länder, die halt mit demokratischen Traditionen eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben. Und die auch sehr dezidierte Vorstellungen davon haben, wie so ein Staat funktioniert und dass es da eine Person gibt und die ist das Gesetz und so fort. Und diese komischen Machtstrukturen und diese Vorstellungen kommen halt über diese Technologie auch nach Europa. Weil die Konzepte, die sich da so entwickeln technisch, da sagen dann die deutschen Dienste, oh ist das toll, wenn man erstmal alle Daten hat, was man da alles für geile Sachen machen kann. Und so verändert sich eigentlich gerade das, was wir hier auch mit unserem demokratischen Selbstverständnis so meinen, Deutschland und in Europa aufgebaut zu haben.
Jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich aber nicht so sein, dass es sagen, dass da nur ein paar Geheimdienstechniker leuchtende Augen kriegen und sagen, hey, die Box wollen wir bei uns auch stehen haben. Sondern das klang ja zwischendurch so ein bisschen durch, dass diese Geheimdienstarbeit oder dieses Überwachungsgelüst auch historisch gewachsen ist. Wir hatten am Anfang schon mal kurz sozusagen, dass es nach dem Zeiten Weltkrieg so war, dass die alliierten sozusagen extra Bewachungsberechtigung hatten. Wie ist denn das eigentlich so jetzt überhaupt in der BRD bis jetzt gewesen, also zu dem Punkt jetzt, wo die großen USA, Großbritannien so einfach mal, wo klar ist, okay, die machen alles, in der BRD sagt, das würden wir auch gerne, gibt uns mal 100 Millionen. Es gab doch wahrscheinlich eine Vorgeschichte dessen. Also eine kleine Historie der deutschen Überwachung.
Warst du mal auf dem Teufelsberg? Andy, weißt du, wer das gebaut hat?
Na ja, der Teufelsberg selbst waren ja Schuttreste von zerstörten Häusern aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Und auf denen haben die Amerikaner, also in diesem Fall nicht die NSA, sondern die sogenannte US INSCOM, das ist der militärische Bereich der Nachrichtendienste, der Intelligenz und Security Communications betreibt, haben eben eine große Schnorchelstation für insbesondere Kommunikation im Ostblock aufgebaut mit riesigen Randomen, wo sie halt sehr weit, weil das war die Station, die zum Zeitalter des Kalten Krieges am nächsten am, das was sie Eisernen Vorhang, also die Mauer oder auch Iron Curtain genannt haben, dran war. Das war halt unter 100 Kilometer am Eisernen Vorhang, wenn ich es richtig rekapituliere. Und die haben halt über Richtfunkstrecken abgehört. Die haben alle möglichen Methoden genutzt, um auch Radarstationen des Ostblocks nicht nur sozusagen wahrzunehmen, sondern auch mit so simulierten Radarbildern dann, um denen zum Beispiel Angriffe zu simulieren, die gar nicht stattgefunden haben. Das nennt man elektronische Kampfführung oder auch Electronic Warfare.
Das ist ja aber jetzt sagen fernab von der Massenüberwachung, wie wir sie heute haben.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen fernab davon. Aber was beim Teufelsberg, wir waren da ja mal drin, und das war wahrscheinlich die andere Hörer auch schon mal, was da ein bisschen beeindruckend drin war, da gab es so 800 Quadratmeter Etagen und davon etliche, wo dann so Auswärter saßen. Das heißt, wo halt auch wirklich Gespräche einfach durch Menschen abgehört wurden. Das war alles damals doch etwas manueller. Das war ja so 70er- 80er-Jahre-Geschichte. Und gut, der Teufelsberg ist jetzt keine aktive Überwachungsstation der Amerikaner mehr. Aber weltweit gibt es noch etliche dieser Stationen. Auch in Deutschland gibt es noch mehrere. Ich war heute morgen zufällig gerade mal in einem Ort namens Griesheim. Das ist bei Darmstadt auf einem August-Euler-Flugplatz, wenn ihr euch das mal googeln wollt. Es gibt da auch noch so ein paar Randome und eine doch beachtliche Anzahl von, also ich habe da so richtig Autos parken gesehen, ich würde sagen ein paar hundert und richtig Leute rumlaufen sehen. Also das wird noch richtig aktiv betrieben. Und in Bad Eiblingen, die große Station der Amerikaner, die auch als Echelonstation berühmt geworden ist, die ist ja auch entgegen der ursprünglichen Planung nie komplett abgebaut worden oder außer Betrieb genommen worden. Also in Deutschland haben wir noch mindestens zwei große dieser Stationen. Und weltweit gibt es, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele.
Was ist dieses Echelon noch mal genau? Der Name fiel schon zwei, drei Mal.
Naja, Echelon war die Bezeichnung in den, ich würde sagen, 90er Jahren für eigentlich dasselbe über das, was wir heute reden, also weltweite Telekommunikationen-Abhörnetz. Ursprünglich war das ein Netz, das hauptsächlich satelitenbasierte Kommunikationen, damals waren die internationalen Glasfasernetze noch nicht so ausgebaut, abgeschnorchelt hat. Die hatten aber auch damals schon verteilte Aufzeichnungen und Auswertungskapazitäten, sogenannte Dictionary-Systeme, wo eben auch nach Suchbegriffen gezielt durchsucht wurde. Und wo ist in einem Zusammenspiel ursprünglich von fünf Staaten, das waren England, Amerika, Neuseeland, Australien und... Was war denn das fünfte jetzt noch?
Das andere Land.
Keiner aufgespricht.
Ja, schlimm.
Also jedenfalls, da war noch ein fünftes Land. Kanada? Ja, dankeschön. Das waren die ursprünglichen fünf. Und es gab dann noch ein paar assoziierte wie Deutschland, die später dazukamen. Also wo jedenfalls erst mal auf diesen fünf Ländern solche Stationen standen, die miteinander vernetzt waren. Und später kamen dann auch etliche Stationen anderer Länder dazu.
Wow, gibt es das eigentlich sozusagen auch in dem kleineren, also die Medien, wir haben ja das Internet noch nicht so lange, gab es eigentlich sozusagen auch sowas Industrielles, industrialisiertes, das hört jetzt ein bisschen ab, ich bin trotzdem gerade neugierig, wie industrialisierte Postüberwachung?
Ja, also es gab mal im Museum für Kommunikation an der Leipziger Straße eine Ausstellung, die hieß Briefe und Fernmittelüberwachung, wenn ich mich recht entsinne. Und was ich da sehr beeindruckend fand, war, da gab es eine Maschine, die war so, ich würde sagen acht Meter lang, wo man stapelweise, allerdings nur genormte A6 oder A4-Umschläge, es gab für beides die Maschinen, Post einlegen konnten. Die wurden dann automatisiert über so eine Förderbandtechnik, über Wasserdampf geführt, die Umschläge aufgemacht, die Briefe rausgezogen, kopiert und wieder zugemacht. Das fand ich ziemlich beeindruckend vor allem. Das war zwar eine von der Stasi eingesetzte Maschine, allerdings aus ordentlicher westdeutscher Produktion.
Du meinst, der Verdacht liegt nahe, dass die nicht nur an die DDR verkauft wurden?
Absolut. Und es gab auch neulich, wenn ihr jetzt das Video dazu sehen wollt, auf bugplanet.de, da gibt's unten wiederum das Video von Dreisart gab's neulich einen Beitrag, das war im November 2012, über DDR-Postkontrolle in der Bundesrepublik, wo schier unglaubliche Interviews mit ehemaligen Bundespostlern bzw. Bundeswehrangestellten, die eben die Post aus der DDR kartonweise, kistenweise aus den Postämtern genommen haben, dann manuell teilweise geöffnet haben, gelesen haben und oftmals weggeschmissen haben. Und da gab's die für mich erst mal auch krasse Zahl zu lernen von 300 Millionen Briefen, die die weggeschmissen haben. aktive Kommunikationsveränderungen, weil die gesagt haben, na ja, a, waren die Sachen ja eh nicht so wichtig und b, in dem Moment, wo man so einen Umschlag nicht so sorgfältig aufgemacht hat, dass er eben nicht mehr verschließbar war, ohne dass man das bemerkt hat, wollte man ja nicht die Methodik offenlegen, dass die Post geöffnet wurde, man wollte das geheim halten. Und dann war es doch einfacher, den Brief wegzuschmeißen, als ihn mühsam wieder zusammenzuflicken.
Zweifel war es dann halt immer der andere Geheimdienst.
Aber da gibt es also in diesem Beitrag von Dreisat, da gibt es so ein Postler, der schier unglaubliche Sätze sagt, es gibt ja nichts geileres als frische, ungeöffnete Privatpost, wo du so denkst, hat er jetzt irgendwie ein sexuelles Problem? Das ist wirklich ein erfrischender 6-Minuten-Beitrag, den man sich zur Kalibrierung seines Bizarrometers zwischendurch mal so angucken kann.
So, jetzt wissen wir Überwachung ist auch nichts Neues, das ist ja alles superschön. Es gab jetzt im Nachgang dieser ganzen Geschichte, sagen auch die Forderungen deutscher Politiker, dass man sagen müsste, wir müssen, also wie formulierst du das jetzt? Ich zitiere mal sinngemäß, könnten wir unter Umständen vielleicht, wenn wir lieb sind, mal darüber reden, was ihr, liebe USA, da gemacht haben? Oder ich fand, eine sehr schöne Interpretation war bei Zeit Online, glaube ich, da hat jemand über diesen Neulandspruch von Angela Merkel gesagt, das Internet ist Neuland und das ist auch alles ein bisschen gefährlich und so. Und er hat gemeint, was Frau Merkel da eigentlich gesagt hat, ist so, das Internet ist halt neu für uns, da kann man auch schon mal aus Versehen so ein bisschen zu viel überwachen.
So wie alles durch Zufall.
Na was ich eigentlich eine viel spannendere Reaktion finde, ist so, was man jetzt von den Innenpolitik-Experten hört. Also du hast, ganz zu Beginn dieses gesamten Skandals stellt sich IM. Friedrich hin und sagt, ja, diese Mischung aus Antiamerikanismus und Naivität in dieser Prism-Sache, keiner wüsste genau, was die machen und trotzdem regen sich alle auf. Das wird ihnen also gehörig auf den Senkel gehen.
Du appellierst jetzt gerade an unsere terroristischen Gelüste, dass du den Mann unbedingt erwähnen musst.
Es kommen noch mehr, es kommen noch mehr. Bosbach und Wiefelspitz habe ich noch auf der Liste. Ja, danke. Die also, die sich dann hinstellen und sagen, naja, hm.
Hat jemand einen Vodka?
Nicht in der Sendung trinken, bitte.
Also Bosbach Union und Wiefelspitz SPD, beide im Innenausschuss, setzen sich dann hin und sagen, ja, also, wenn das aber jetzt so ein großes Ausmaß hat, dass da die US-Dienste die Services in den USA abhören, dann müssen wir aber jetzt mal hier ein paar 100 Millionen Infrastrukturförderungen machen und die Deutschland-Cloud und das D-Mail und das alles wieder, unsere Daten wieder nach Deutschland holen, wo wir sie dann abhören können und die...
Nein, dürfen wir ja nicht. Also dürfen sie offiziell nicht. Aber es ist schon ein geiler Standortvorteil. Unsere Datenschutzparanoia plötzlich als Standortvorteil. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Also die Strategie, die Idee dahinter ist doch klar, dass kein Staat Bock hat, dass ein anderer die eigene, da irgendwie großartig seine Fühler reinhaut.
Das könnte man meinen, aber wenn du dir anguckst, dass die Deutschen beispielsweise, der Bundesnachentienst, hat ja diese Befugnis der strategischen Fernmeldüberwachung und wie sich das erklärt, dass die Amis sich dann auf Folien damit brüsten, dass die ja alles von den Deutschen bekommen, da stellt man sich ja schon die Frage, also wo sind wir und wer sind wir eigentlich?
Na, da kommen natürlich solche Meldungen dann gerne mal.
Ja, von unseren Steuergeldern, wie so ein System aufgebaut, was uns irgendwie hinter unserem Rücken verrät, ist eigentlich nicht in unserem Interesse und sollte da eigentlich auch mal aktiv.
Dazu kommen wir noch. Ich wollte jetzt noch mal nachfragen. Also die Politiker sagen, Leute, es ist ja eh schon immer so, also die amerikanischen Firmen sind die Datenschleudern, jetzt lasst ihr sie ja noch überwachen, macht mal hier in Deutschland sozusagen eine deutsche Cloud-Anbieter, die email, also die email, okay. Ja, genau, aber sie sagen, die argumentieren das zumindest jetzt erst mal vordergründig schon so, dass sie sagen, wir brauchen sichere Daten übertragen oder nicht? Oder sagen die gleich, lasst euch mal bitte von uns überwachen?
Das sagen sie natürlich nicht, dass man sich von ihnen dann überwachen soll, ist aber auch natürlich das im Rahmen der Wirtschaftsförderung nun gebotene Argument zu sagen, ach übrigens T-Systems macht doch auch Lösungen und es ist doch sowieso falsch, dass die ganzen mittelständischen Unternehmen irgendwie US-Dienste nutzen und nicht irgendwie die T-Systems Deutschland klaut, wo die doch so viel besser ist. Die ist nur auch nicht sicherer, die ist genauso unverschlüsselt.
Jetzt wollte ich gerade sagen, die E-Mail ist doch dieses System, wo E-Mails verschlüsselt werden sollen, die aber einmal beim Anbieter entschlüsselt werden. Also genau an dem Punkt, wo Geheimdienste möglicherweise...
Willst du noch was wissen? Ich hab da noch... Was da nämlich jetzt noch rausgekommen ist, gab es so große Stirnrunzeln, die Geheimdienste haben gesagt, wir speichern auch sämtlichen verschlüsselten Traffic weg. Und alle gucken sich um. Ja gut, viel Spaß beim Entschlüsseln. Dann kommen dann die Leute, die sich SSL, also dieses Protokoll, was man in der Browserkommunikation benutzt, angeguckt hat und gemeint, na ja, wenn die das alles wegschreiben und später mal den Server hopsen, mit dem Secret Key drauf, dann können die die Verbindung alle entschlüsseln, auch nachträglich, rückwirkend. Also es ist keineswegs so, dass die Geheimdienste, die da den verschlüsselten Traffic mal so auf Halde mit bevorraten, dass die dann nachher da nichts mit anfangen können.
Also bei dem SSL muss man sagen, es ist schon verschlüsselt, aber die werden sozusagen einer der beiden Kommunikationspartner bei verschlüsselter Kommunikation...
Nicht der Server. Bei SSL immer der, der angerufen wird.
Also es handelt sich eben nicht um End-zu-End-Verschlüsselung, wo auch der Mann in der Mitte sozusagen überhaupt keine Chance hat, das abzugreifen, sondern es ist genau das Gegenteil. Es ist nur eine Transportwegverschlüsselung zum Server und somit liegt das Zeug auf dem Server im Zweifelsfall unverschlüsselt.
Oder hat den Schlüssel für die Verschlüsselung daneben liegen. Das wäre dann bei demel der Fall. Sie sagen, wir speichern es verschlüsselt, können es aber auch wieder entschlüsseln. Das heißt also, ne, ne, wir schließen das ein, wir haben nur auch den Schlüssel.
Der am Brett neben der Tür hängt.
Das kannst du dir sparen.
Und dann kommt er dazu, dass auch die meiste verschlüsselte Kommunikation vertraut ja dem Server auf der anderen Seite mit so Zertifikaten, die, naja, nicht nur die Firma selber unterschreiben kann, sondern diese Zertifikate, die dort als Root-Zertifikate in dem Browser eingebaut sind. Also da, wo man dem jetzt vertraut, weil man glaubt, das könnte ja eigentlich nur von Google unterzeichnet werden, ist es in Wirklichkeit so, dass eigentlich jeder, der so einen Key hat oder irgendein, der damit signiert ist, kann auch selber beliegen.
Ich glaube, jetzt wird's gerade wieder richtig schwierig, aber wir hatten ein Chaosradio zu genau diesem Thema. Wir hatten mal ein ganzes Chaosradio zur SSL-Verschüstung. Ich weiß die Nummer gerade nicht. Aber wenn man sich sagen, jetzt genau angucken will, wo die Angriffspunkte sind, kann man das gerne noch mal nachhören. Ich würde jetzt eigentlich gerne zu dem Punkt kommen, wo ich... Also Andy hat im Vorbereitungssendung schon gesagt, er mag so Told-you-so-Sprüche. Wir haben es ja immer gewusst. Trotzdem würde ich von euch gerne mal wissen, inwieweit das, was man jetzt gerade für die Öffentlichkeit vielleicht überraschend ist oder was man jetzt gerade lernt, eine Überraschung ist oder beziehungsweise, wie ihr das bewertet.
Wie man das bewährt? Also eine Überraschung, nachdem ich Preislisten gesehen hab, was da so DPI-Software, also diese, nicht Software-Hardware, diese Büchsen, die man in so ein Rechenzentrum reinstellt, um da mal beliebige Gigabit-Leitungen komplett bis in die Tiefe die Protokolle auseinandernehmen zu können, dort in Verbindung Kram reinzuschleusen. Was kostet da so eine Box, irgendwie 30.000 Euro und macht dort schon die Hälfte der Kunden. Seitdem ich irgendwie das gesehen hab, fünf, sechs Jahre her, war da für mich diese Ausrede, dass mit so großen Datenmengen keiner was anfangen kann. Das kann man nicht effizient filtern, kann man nichts speichern. War dann einfach hinfällig und auch schon um fort. Man hat ihm ja immer alles Mögliche Böse zugetraut. Was mich überrascht hat, ist, dass so eine große Welle geschlagen hat. Wahrscheinlich weil das Prisma so ein schönes Logo war und die Amerikaner sich das erste Mal selbst überwacht fühlten und bisher glaubten, es würde ja nur die bösen Terroristen und die lauter Ausländer betreffen. Oder vielleicht weil die Republikaner an den Vereinigten Staaten auch dem Präsidenten mal ans Bein pinkeln wollten, wo sie die Gelegenheit gesehen haben. Mich überrascht eher, dass es jetzt so ganz groß aufkocht.
Du hast die technische Möglichkeit wahrgenommen, dass das schon geht. Du bist aber gleichzeitig davon ausgegangen, dass es auch gemacht wird.
Na, irgendjemand muss es ja kaufen. Wie üblicherweise skalieren die Preise bei solchen Boxen werden ja nicht so günstig, wenn es nicht woanders im großen Stil deployed wird. Und irgendjemand muss die ja kaufen. Und so viele brauchen üblicherweise die privaten Anbieter nicht, um da ihre paar Kunden da zurecht zu filtern. Also muss irgendjemand anders die Preise nach unten getrieben haben. Und da war dann für mich klar, da sind irgendwo anders riesige Mengen davon verbaut worden.
Na, im Prinzip ähnlich. Also mein persönliches Verhalten im Netz ist eh ohnehin davon gekennzeichnet, dass ich immer davon ausgehe, dass das alles in den Händen anderer Leute landet. Und ich mich deshalb halt persönlich versuche, irgendwie davor zu schützen oder irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass ich ganz ruhig schlafen kann mit den Dingen, die ich so mache. Ich habe persönlich, insbesondere was das Speichern angeht, so ein bisschen meine Zweifel gehabt.
Dass sie diese ganzen Datenmengen vorhalten?
Ja, also die Vorhaltezeiten habe ich da sicherlich noch mal ein bisschen unterschätzt. Was aber die parallele Verarbeitung und auch die Live-Verarbeitung solcher Daten angeht, braucht man sich da nichts vorzumachen. Also wenn das ein normaler Netzprovider hinkriegt, dann nur für seine 20-30 Millionen Kunden, warum sollten das nicht Geheimdienste dann auch für einen Faktor davon hinkriegen?
Der passt nicht auf.
Da hat doch bestimmt wieder einer aus deinem Bildschirm geguckt. Die Frage ist sozusagen, wie du diese Nachricht aufgenommen hast. Also ob dich das irgendwie überrascht hat oder was deine Reaktion darauf war.
Ich beschäftige mich damit schon ein bisschen länger, so 20 Jahre oder so. Und ich hab meine Aha-Momente schon etwas früher gehabt. Ich hab beispielsweise mal zufällig einen Staatssekretär bei mir am Auto gehabt, der bei den sogenannten 2 plus 4 Gesprächen mit dabei war. Also da, wo der Kanzler Kohl mit den Alliierten die Wiedervereinigung ausgehandelt hat. Und der hat mir eine ganz komische Geschichte erzählt, nämlich, dass die Amis halt gesagt haben, irgendwie könnte alles haben mit der Wiedervereinigung. Aber die Sache mit der Telekommunikation, die wollen wir weiterhin haben. Und der Kohl, der wusste gar nicht, worum es ging. Also der hat aus Sicht seines Beraterstab, das war ihm alles so abstrakt. Und dann haben die, um ihm sozusagen das plastisch vor Augen zu halten, bei der Gaug-Behörde mal die Überwachungstranskripte der Kohlischen Telefongespräche der letzten 20 Jahre angefordert. Das waren so drei Aktenwagen voller Papier, die sie dann ins Kanzleramt gerollt haben. Und der Kohl so, was ist denn dit? Und die so, naja Herr Kohl, das sind die Mitschnitte, also die aufgezeichneten und niedergeschriebenen Transkripte eben ihrer aufgezeichneten Telefongespräche der 20 Jahre, inklusiv ihrer persönlichen und sonstigen privaten und so fort. Und da hat der Kohl möglicherweise dann auch verstanden, worum es ging. Aber so hat der Mann mir ausgeführt, war es so, dass der Kohl eigentlich mit den Amis überhaupt nicht verhandelt hat, sondern der hat ihre Bedingungen akzeptiert und fertig. Und das heißt, er wollte gar nicht mit denen argumentieren. Und das fand ich, kann ich natürlich nicht nachweisen, und das ist doch alles nie passiert, ich werd auch keinen Namen nennen, aber das fand ich einen interessanten Einblick in, wie das da so läuft. Und wie dann so mal kurz die Privatsphäre der deutschen Telefonbenutzer sozusagen mal kurz in so einem politischen Akt über den Jordan gehen.
Aber würde das jetzt einen Unterschied machen bei den technischen Gegebenheiten, die wir jetzt beobachten?
Na ja, wir haben halt im Moment nicht mal die Möglichkeit, könnte man auf die Decke und das sagen, wenigstens innerdeutsch wollen wir doch irgendwie da mal keine fremden Nachhinde, die sie drin haben und nicht mal die Möglichkeit gibt es. Und das finde ich schon. Also Petra Kelly hat ja mal bei den Grünen, so am Anfangszeit der Grünen, die Idee gehabt, bevor sie dann wahrscheinlich wegen dieser Idee sterben musste, dass die Deutschen noch eigentlich mal zur NATO austreten sollten und sich überhaupt mal frei machen sollten von diesem militärischen Mitengagement bei irgendwelchen westlichen und sonstigen Blöcken. Und das wäre die einzige Chance gewesen aus diesem NATO-Truppenstatut und damit dieser Verpflichtung, auch denen in Zugriff auf unsere Telekommunikationen und so zu ermöglichen, auszusteigen.
So, das haben wir leider nicht geschafft. Jetzt haben wir den Salat, könnte man sagen. Und das ist der Punkt, wo ich euch auch noch mal gerne aufrufen möchte, anzurufen.
Eure Meinung jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Denn wir wollen doch noch mal ein bisschen über die gesellschaftliche Reaktion auch sprechen. Weil was ich jetzt wahrgenommen habe, ist, wenn man vor einem Monat noch gesagt hat, wir werden alle überwacht, und zwar alles immer. Dann wurde man so als Adelhutspinner abgetan. Du bist doch verrückt. Und hier, ich stell dir nicht so an, das ist doch totaler Quatsch. Jetzt ist es so, dass das, was ich so wahrnehme, ist, na ja klar, wir werden halt alle überwacht. Ist halt eben so. Woran glaubt ihr liegt es, dass es keinen Protest, keine Aufregung, kein Irgendwas gibt? Ist das so normal? Stellt ihr euch da vielleicht besonders an, wenn ihr sagt, Überwachung ist eigentlich doof? Also es scheint ja sozusagen nichts Größeres. Also die Medien gucken auf diesen Typen, auf den Snowden, berichten jetzt Geschichten über denen. Das andere läuft so ein bisschen nebenher. Aber es gibt keine größere Reaktion.
Ich finde dieses Beispiel aus Großbritannien, wo wirklich Leute, die sich einfach nicht zu Schulden kommen, haben lassen, die einfach Baumschützer gewesen sind, und keinerlei terroristische Bestrebungen, keinerlei... Ich mein, wie einfach Otto Normalbürger, die wurden unterwandert. Und obwohl sie eigentlich nichts zu verbergen haben hätten sollen, wurde ihnen dort der gesamte Überwachungsapparat des Landes auf den Hals gehetzt und hat dort Leben ruiniert. Und du kannst einfach dadurch, dass du überwacht wirst und irgendeine Maschine plötzlich der Meinung ist, dass du in irgendein bestimmtes Raster reinfällst, was schon mal schlecht riecht, dass du dann plötzlich, egal was du glaubst, nicht verbergen haben hätten zu wollen, dir so umgedreht werden kann, dass du plötzlich im orangenen Anzug irgendwo auf einer Karibik-Insel schwitzt.
Ja, aber das ist zu sagen deine Ansicht. Warum ist das denn sozusagen in einer weiteren Gesellschaft zu sagen? Ich möchte eigentlich sagen, es gibt gar keine Reaktion. Für mich wirkt das so, wie die Leute sitzen halt da, haben hier einen Popcorn einmal in der Hand und gucken sich das an. Das ist halt total spannend.
Vielleicht in deiner Bubble so, die Leute, die es vorher schon wirklich wussten.
Weiß ich nicht. Es gibt ja zwei Probleme. Das eine Problem ist, dass für viele Leute das immer noch sehr abstrakt ist. Und das andere Problem ist, dass selbst die, die es verstehen, die es nicht abstrakt ist, sondern die es auch verstehen und nicht so toll finden, dass sie natürlich die Frage stellen, was kann ich denn jetzt machen? Wir haben ja einen Innenminister, der nicht mal die Debatte darüber führen will. Wir haben irgendwie eine Kanzlerin, die nicht mal versteht, worum es geht. Also wir werden da teilweise noch regiert von Leuten, die sind scheinbar im Röhrenradio aufgewachsen und haben noch große Probleme zu verstehen, was die Informationssphäre ist, in der die Bevölkerung sich so befindet. Also das ist ja so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie in der Türkei, wo scheinbar der Innenminister sich nur die Frage stellt, wie man dieses Twitter-Ding ins Abschaltet und aber noch nie verstanden hat, dass das nicht an einem neuen Medium liegt, sondern vielleicht auch an was anderem, wenn die neuen Medien so Nachrichten emporbringen, dass sie unzufrieden mit der Regierung sind.
Sie haben aber untersichert trotzdem die Leute sitzen, die den ganzen Kram dann doch abhören können. Also im Moment, ich komm zu deiner Frage, ich hab sie nicht ignoriert. Die Reaktion in den USA, da gab es ja eigentlich nur eine Empörung darüber, dass sie unter Umständen Amerikaner abhören. US-Amerikaner. Das ist ja auch so ein kulturelles Ding. Der Thomas Drake war dieses Jahr beim Kongress in Hamburg. Auch so ein NSA-Whistleblower. Er hat offensichtlich seinen Standardvortrag gehalten. Er hat da so ein riesiges Ding und immer wieder betont, dass er ja ein Amerikaner ist und das trotzdem ihm nachspioniert würde. Das heißt, die haben da so eine völlig skurrile Auffassung von. Die haben wirklich ein Problem damit, wenn sie betroffen sind. In Deutschland hast du Kolumnisten in großen Zeitungen? Also ja, sagen wir jetzt mal Kolumnisten. Also irgendwie dieser Franz Josef Wagner, der dann schreibt, ich bin lieber überwacht als tot.
Nackt als tot?
Nee, lieber überwacht als tot.
Ich glaube, ich meine, ich habe so irgendwas gelesen. Ich weiß, völlig egal.
Beides ist eine, ich meine, gut, und du kannst das Argument zu erklären, warum das falsch ist, dauert länger als das falsche Argument, in dem du einfach behauptest, ja, aber damit schützen wir euch doch vor dem Terror. Also dieser Begriff des großen Bruders, den wir auch im Sendungstitel haben, der trifft da ja auch zu. Also so gibt sich ja der Staat tatsächlich. Also nach innen sieht man jetzt die USA, stellen sich hin und sagen, und schaffen es sogar, dass ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung wütend ist auf Edward Snowden, dass er das veröffentlicht hat. Du liest heute auf CNN-Meldungen, dass die Terroristen jetzt aufgrund der Veröffentlichung Snowdens ihre Strategie ändern. Ja, also mit so einer Meldung, ja, die liest du, und dann denken die Leute, vielleicht sind die US-Medien schon weiter.
Vielleicht meinten sie mit den Terroristen da die Nachrichtendienste.
Man weiß es nicht genau. Wir werden aber auf jeden Fall gleich noch drüber sprechen, was ihr davon haltet und was man möglicherweise dagegen tun kann. Vorher müssen wir noch eine ganz, ganz kleine kurze Pause machen fürs Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Zuerst wollte er in der Kolumbiale spielen, aber die war ganz schnell ausverkauft. Dann wollte er in der Arena spielen. Aber die war auch ganz schnell ausverkauft. Jetzt will er in der O2 World spielen. Aber... Nee, nix aber. Born McLemore geht einfach nicht. Fritz präsentiert. McLemore. Mittwoch, 25. September. McLemore. Live in Berlin. More McLemore geht einfach nicht.
Präsentiert von Fritz. Immer gute neue Musik.
Um kurze halb zwölf. Nachricht mit Golo Schmid.
Die Staats- und Regierungschefs der Europäischen Union haben am frühen Abend ihren Gipfel in Brüssel begonnen, Bundeskanzlerin Merkel knüpfte ihre Zustimmung zu einem Solidaritätsfonds für die Eurozone an Bedingungen. Es könne nicht darum gehen, immer wieder neue Finanz-Töpfe zu schaffen, sagte Merkel. Vielmehr müsse die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der europäischen Länder verbessert werden. Dazu sind nach Ansicht Merkels weitere Reformen nötig. Hauptthema der zweitägigen Beratung sind das weitere wirtschaftliche Wachstum und die hohe Jugendarbeitslosigkeit in Europa. Die Fraktionschefin der Grünen im Bundestag Künast hat die deutsche Blockade strengerer EU-Abgasnormen für Autos kritisiert. Künast sprach von Lobbyarbeit für die Interessenten, für die Interessen von Autokonzernen. Greenpeace warf der Bundesregierung vor, demokratische Prozesse zu kidnappen. Zuvor war bekannt geworden, dass die EU-Botschafter offenbar auf Druck aus Berlin hin eine endgültige Festlegung bei den Abgasnormen verschoben hatten. Erst Anfang der Woche hatte sich die EU auf neue Klimaschutzvorgaben verständigt. Die deutsche Autoindustrie hatte diese massiv kritisiert. Im Fall des ehemaligen Geheimdienstmitarbeiters Snowden verschlechtert sich die Stimmung zwischen den USA und Ecuador. Das südamerikanische Land kündigte ein Zollabkommen mit der Regierung in Washington. Die USA hatten vorher selbst damit gedroht, den Handelsvertrag aufzulösen. Hintergrund ist, dass der amerikanische Ex-Geheimdienstmitarbeiter Snowden Asyl in Ecuador beantragt hat. Die USA wollen ihn vor Gericht stellen, weil er die Abhörprogramme von amerikanischen und britischen Geheimdiensten aufgedeckt hatte. Die türkische Regierung ermittelt jetzt auch in sozialen Netzwerken gegen Regierungskritiker. Die Polizei sucht unter anderem bei Facebook und Twitter nach Bürgern, die angeblich Staatsvertreter beleidigt haben. In der Türkei laufen seit knapp einem Monat Proteste gegen die Regierung von Ministerpräsident Erdogan. Die Polizei schlug Demos immer wieder gewaltsam nieder, vor allem in Istanbul.
Wetter.
Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Zehlendorf sind es 12, in Treptow 14 Grad. Frankfurt-Oder und Grünow jeweils 12, Ludwigsfelde und Küritz jeweils 13 Grad. Heute Nacht bleibt es trotz vieler Wolken meistens trocken, die Temperaturen gehen auf 11 bis 7 Grad runter und der Tagmorgen fängt sonnig an, im Laufe des Tages sind aber Regen und Gewitter möglich, bei maximal 20 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin 100 Stadtring zwischen Tunnel Innsbrucker Platz und Albuinstraße ist in beiden Richtungen die linke Spur wegen einer Baustelle gesperrt. Auch auf der 111 Stadtautobahn Zubringer Uranienbrook ist zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdamm, Hermsdorferdamm und Schulzendorfer Straße in beiden Richtungen nur eine Spur frei, Grund ist ja eine Baustelle. Und an 115 Abus Richtung Dreieck-Potsdam zwischen Hüttenweg und Kreuz Zehlendorf ist die linke Spur wegen Reinigungsarbeiten gesperrt. Ansonsten Rollts euch ne gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby. Die Fritz App.
Und das hört man.
Ja, wie ihr am Sendungsbeginn hört, ist die Sendung chaotisch. Das ist Blue, die zwei Sprechstunden. Und das hört man.
Neumann!
Ja, wie ihr am Sendungsbeginn hört, ist die Sendung chaotisch, was natürlich daran liegt, dass es das Chaos Radio ist vom Chaos Computer Club, wo wir heute über Prism, Tempora, GZ HQ und über Überwachung reden, über Telekom, Neoklass und Überwachung. Wir haben jetzt gerade schon anderthalb Stunden lang erklärt, was passiert ist, wo das herkommt, was der historische Kontext ist, wie die das technisch machen, also die ganzen Sachen, die wir jetzt nicht noch mal kurz in zwei Minuten zusammenfassen können. Ihr könnt das Ganze aber als Podcast hören, wenn ihr wollt, wenn die Sendung erstmal vorbei ist. Jetzt sprechen wir darüber, was ihr davon haltet. Ganz kurz und dann werden wir uns noch damit beschäftigen, was man möglicherweise dagegen machen kann. So, da haben wir als erstes den Martin, 28 aus Potsdam. Hallo Martin. Was hältst du von der ganzen Sache?
Also so groß überrascht bin ich nicht, weil so Eheheimdienste hatten jetzt noch nie Newtonruf und die haben ja schon immer irgendwelche fiesen Sachen gemacht. Ich kann mir aber auch nicht richtig vorstellen, dass die letztendlich darauf aus sind, irgendwie die Demokratie groß zu unterwandern. Und ich stelle mir das auch so vor, dass das jetzt mit den Baumschützern in England so ein separater Ding war, weil ich meine Greenpeace hieb das noch. Und ich kann mir nicht richtig vorstellen, dass die Eheheimdienste da so ein großes Interesse haben, die Demokratie zu unterwandern und dass das jetzt so gefährlich ist.
Was darf ich dich kurz fragen, wenn du sagst unterwandern? Also ich meine, was ist denn dein Verständnis von Demokratie? Demokratie besteht ja eigentlich nicht nur aus alle ab und zu mal Wählen, sondern auch aus so Grundrechten, zum Beispiel auf die Unversehrtheit und die Privatsphäre und so.
Ja, aber da standen die Eheheimdienste ja schon immer drüber auch.
Na super. Also auf einen Fall hast du recht, die wollen die nicht unterwandern, die wollen die bloß abschaffen.
Warte mal, also... Nee, nee, die profitieren ja auch schon. So, Martin, ich muss dich mal nachfragen. Also meinst du, dass sozusagen das war schon immer so und deswegen wird es auch weiterhin so sein? Oder meinst du, du findest das gut?
Ich find es nicht gut. Ich find es halt so wie immer, nur ist man jetzt ein Stück schlauer.
Du findest es also auch nicht besonders besorgniserregend?
Na doch, ist schon ein bisschen unheimlich. Ab und zu gucke ich auf meinen Rechner und werde paranoid, aber es geht noch.
Konkrete Gegenmaßnahmen hast du noch nicht ergriffen?
Nee, obwohl mich jetzt, ja, Iqvador interessiert mich jetzt tierisch. Und alle Spionen wollen nach Iqvador.
Das ist aber eine ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz andere Sendung. Aber okay, Martin, ich halte mal fest, so ein bisschen gruselig, aber ganz schlimm ist es nicht. So, dann haben wir den Ampi. Hallo. So, was hältst du von der ganzen Sache?
Ja, also ich find's auch schlimm, dass so wenig Widerspruch ist in der Bevölkerung. Und Obama war ja vor kurzem hier und das wär die Gelegenheit gewesen, halt quasi die Meinung zu sagen. Aber stattdessen stehen wir halt mit hunderttausend von Leuten vom Brandenburger Tor und sehen dazu wie der...
Hand ausgewählte Leute auch noch. Das war ja, dass da alles abgesperrt war und dann durfte eigentlich kaum jemand hin. Dann haben sie dann einen Wimpelträger. Das ist wie in der DDR eigentlich, dass dann wieder die Leute mit den Wink-Elementen da wieder in den Vordur stehen. Oh, dieser Erdgeist.
Na, aber in der DDR hatten die Wink-Elemente wenigstens der Friedenstauber als Symbol. Also das finde ich jetzt ist eine Diskreditierung der DDR.
Ampi, wirst du jetzt irgendwie gesonderte Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen?
Gesonderte Gegenmaßnahmen? Ja, man denkt ja, ich habe viel darüber nachgedacht. Und man hört ja dann auch wiederum, dass man, also man denkt dann über Anonymisierung nach, mit Netzwerken wie Tor. Aber dann hört man auch, die haben auch ihre eigenen Tor Exit-Notes drin und sehen dann quasi mit dem Verkehr auch mit. Und da weiß man halt am Ende gar nicht mehr, was man machen soll.
Okay, na vielleicht können wir noch den restlichen verbleibenden Minuten ein kleines Licht darauf werfen.
Ja, aber ich glaube schon, wenn jeder das machen würde, wäre es ja total anonym, mehr oder weniger. Aber gut, ich meine, ich versuche mich halt aufzuklären und ich glaube, ich versuche mich da auch irgendwie ein bisschen zu verselbstständigen und ein bisschen Schritt zu halten.
Abzulösen. Und dann haben wir noch den Nabil aus der Amstatt. Hallo, guten Abend. Was hältst du von der ganzen Sache?
Ich möchte eigentlich direkt an meinen Vorredner anschließen, weil darauf sollte ich hinaus, dass die, also ich in meinem Bekannkreis viele würden gerne verschlüsseln, würden sich gerne ein bisschen dagegen wehren. Natürlich gibt es auch leider die Großzahl der Menschen, denen das irgendwie egal zu sein scheint. Aber das ganz, ganz große Problem ist, weil gerade bei Verschlüsselung, dass das alles sehr, sehr schwer zugänglich ist. Also ich bin mittlerweile 25, ich bin 25, ich hab mit sechs angefangen, am Rechner rumzumachen. Und also PGP zum Beispiel bei der E-Mail einzurichten. Das war für mich dann auch noch eine Herausforderung, wenn ich mir dann vorstelle, dass so ein relativ unbedarfter Mensch sich dagegen wehren soll oder mal anfangen soll, sich damit zu befassen. Das ist alles einfach noch viel zu kompliziert. Und wir müssen einfach lernen, dass zur Sicherheit oder dass ein Sicherheitsmerkmal auch die Zugänglichkeit und die einfache Anwendung von Sicherheitstechnik ist.
Also dass das quasi entwickelt werden muss auf eine Art und Weise, dass das auch jeder benutzen kann.
Richtig, weil wenn das, das kann, also natürlich ist die grundsätzliche Sicherheit natürlich das Kernelement. Aber wenn das nur der letzte Ultrageek benutzen kann, dann ist das halt nutzlos. Dann können wir uns die Arbeitsprinzip im Prinzip auch sparen, weil es die große Masse nicht verwenden wird. Wie er gesagt hat, wenn wir alle mit Tor rumsurfen würden, wär das wahrscheinlich zum Beispiel auch viel schneller. Macht aber keiner, weil das wahrscheinlich trotz des Tor-Bundles noch viel zu kompliziert ist einzusetzen.
Okay, können wir vielleicht gleich noch mal zu sprechen kommen? Erstmal vielen Dank und frohes Surfen noch. Und dann haben wir ganz zum Schluss noch den Bernd aus Pankow. Hallo Bernd. Was hättest du von der ganzen Sache?
Na ja, ich sag mal, auch für mich war es nicht so überraschend, zumal das Internet im Prinzip ja auch ursprünglich ein militärisches Projekt war und wenn alle Hauptknotenpunkte in den USA sind, dann wär die NS8 ziemlich blöd da nicht ranzugehen. Daher hat es mich jetzt so nicht umgehauen. Aber das machen ja, ich denke, auch wirklich alle, wie es schon in der Sendung angesprochen wurde. Und ich glaube mal, wenn der BND ein bisschen cleverer wäre und seine 20% schaffen würde, dann, ich hab sowieso die Frage, wenn die sagen, 20% zur Auslandskommunikation, wenn die Daten sowieso alle über die USA gehen, heißt das da nicht auch 20% von allem?
Von allem was?
Na von aller Kommunikation. Der BND hat das Recht, 20% der Kommunikation mit dem Ausland sozusagen zu überwachen.
Ja, aber nicht alle Auslandskommunikationen wird über Deutschland geroutet. Und der BND muss ja auch erstmal mit seinen Fühlern da rankommen.
Ach so, das heißt der BND überwacht sozusagen nur das, was komplett außerhalb Deutschlands läuft.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige Frage, die tatsächlich ganz so eindeutig nicht ist. Darüber habe ich hier deswegen klappert. Da ist zwischendurch hier so ein bisschen, ich chatte da über diese Frage gerade mit jemandem. Also es gibt ein deutsches Gesetz, dieses G10-Gesetz. Und dort gibt es den sogenannten dritten Abschnitt. Und der dritte Abschnitt nennt sich die strategischen Beschränkungen. Und da gibt es den ersten Satz, den kann ich kurz vorlesen, auf Antrag des Bundesnachrichtendienstes dürfen Beschränkungen nach blablabla für internationale Telekommunikationssitzungen, soweit eine gebündelte Betreuung erfolgt, angeordnet werden. Das heißt zunächst einmal, das klingt so wie, die dürfen auf den Auslandsbündeln, also beispielsweise auf den Faserleitungen, die von Deutschland nach Frankreich, Polen oder sonst wo hingehen, dürfen die drauf sitzen. Und dann diese 20-Prozent-Geschichte, die kommt viel später. Erstmal ist ja das Entscheidende, dass sie die komplett abgreifen können. Nun ist das aber gar nicht so eindeutig, ob die tatsächlich auf den Auslandsbündeln sitzen oder ob die nicht auf sehr zentralen Telekom-Punkten setzen, wo unter anderem auch die Auslandsbündel abgehindert werden. Das heißt, entweder die Telekom filtert, was sie dem BND geben und was außer an was Inland ist, oder die tun das. Das kann ich dir heute noch nicht auflösen, das wird wahrscheinlich mein morgiger Arbeitsag sein, so ungefähr. Aber da gibt es tatsächlich gerade Leute, die mir sagen, dass die Telekom alles übergibt und dass die dann filtern.
Ja, würde mich auch nicht wundern.
Ja, würde mich ein bisschen wundern, weil das wäre dann so was wie, es gibt im Strafrecht die Formulierung, wenn man, wenn du mit 130 durch eine 30er-Zone fährst, wo ein Kindergarten ist und dann überfährst du ein Kind, dann nennt man das billigend in Kauf nehmen. Und das wäre hier so ein bisschen so was Ähnliches, weil wenn man Nachrichtendienst alle Kommunikationen gibt und sagt, aber ihr haltet euch schön an die Gesetze und filtert nur das raus, was ihr dürft. Also das ist ja völlig...
Na gut, du hast ja selbst gesagt, dass den Geheimdienst ja im Prinzip außerhalb des Gesetzes steht.
Ja, ja, Legalitätsprinzip war so das Opportunitätsprinzip. Völlig richtig. Trotzdem gibt es ja theoretisch noch juristische Grundlagen, an die sich die halten müssen, zumindest die Deutschen an die deutschen Gesetze. Aber naja, das würden wir noch herausfinden müssen.
Bernd, noch ganz kurze Frage. Willst du konkret was unternehmen?
Ähm, ehrlich gesagt nein. Einerseits ist es so, ich bin mir immer nicht sicher, Verschlüsselung, ja, ist natürlich ein Thema. Andererseits könnte sowas erst recht interessant sein. Bei den Supercomputern, die die NSL da irgendwo zu stehen hat, bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob eine Verschlüsselung mit einem normalen Passwort, was man sich auch merken kann, da überhaupt irgendeine Hürde darstellt und ob das das Ganze noch viel interessanter macht für die. Und zum anderen, da ich auch nicht in sozialen Netzwerken aktiv bin und kaum irgendwie, also bis auf die üblichen Webseiten, besuche, was mache ich, ist es für mich persönlich, denke ich, optimistischerweise nicht so wichtig. Wobei ich sagen muss, die Dystopien, die ich in den letzten Chaos Computer Sendungen über die Jahre hinweg gehört hab, die haben sich ja fast immer bewahrheitet.
Ja, also ich würde tatsächlich auch empfehlen, einfach die Sendung nochmal ganz von vorne zu hören, weil es ist tatsächlich egal, ob du persönlich kommunizierst oder nur Netz hörst, da lassen sich auch sehr interessante Profile draus machen. Bernd, dir vielen Dank auf jeden Fall. So, jetzt haben wir noch ein paar Minuten Zeit, um sozusagen ein paar Gegenmaßnahmen zu besprechen. Gut, ich wollte jetzt erstmal nach den gesellschaftlichen Gegenmaßnahmen, das wäre also Geheimdienste abschaffen? Weißt du, das würde helfen?
Wir haben leider hier in Deutschland wenig Einfluss darauf, US-amerikanische Geheimdienste abzuschaffen, aber man kann ja hier in Deutschland schon mal anfangen. Also so richtig doll was gebracht, haben uns deutsche Geheimdienste irgendwie mal...
Doch, den NSU-Skandal.
Erstimmend.
Das ist eine jahrelange Unterhaltung.
Das hat uns vereint vor den Tagesschau...
Ich würde da tatsächlich sagen, ungern. Ich komme jetzt nicht auf den Namen, aber ein Mitglied der türkischen Gemeinde in Deutschland hat damals einen Kommentar gemacht, dass es in Deutschland scheinbar auch den Tiefen Staat gibt. Mit tiefer Staat ist das gemeint, was wohl in der Türkei etwas, zumindest nach dortiger Betrachtung, vorhanden ist. Nämlich so eine Mischung aus einer militärischen, industriellen Angelegenheit und einem scheinbar demokratischen, normalen Rechtsstaat. Und wir wandern hier so ein bisschen in so eine ähnliche Sache rein. Das heißt, eigentlich müssen wir ja auch irgendwie... Verfassungsschutz wäre ja theoretische Verteidigung der Verfassung gegen die, die sie abschaffen wollen. Aber wenn es eben ausgerechnet die nachrichtlichen Strukturen sind, dann muss man die abschaffen, um die Verfassung zu schützen.
Das wäre also das politische, das wir möglicherweise heute nicht mehr hinkriegen. Jetzt fällt immer im Zusammenhang mit dieser Überwachung so, man könnte ja verschlüsseln. Hilft das tatsächlich was, wenn man seine, sagen wir mal, Mails oder Chats oder was auch immer so an direkter Kommunikation anfällt, verschlüsselt?
Das kommt darauf an, wie man verschlüsselt.
Also ja, es hilft. Also kann man erst mal grundsätzlich sagen, dass es immer wenig Grund gibt, keine Krypto zu benutzen. Heutzutage ist es echt billig geworden, Dinge erst mal opportunistisch zu verschlüsseln. Dann kann man mal gucken, ob die Webseiten, die man so besucht, ob man die nicht denn doch über die SSL verschlüsselte Version benutzt. Und da kann man schon mal wenigstens irgendwie anfangen und die Angst verlieren, vielleicht irgendwie in den täglichen Workflow zu übernehmen, mit Leuten verschlüsselt E-Mails auszutauschen, macht ja dann auch, dass man dann weniger Berührungsängste hat, wenn einen jemand anders fragt.
Jetzt, ein häufiges Gegenteil, wenn was gegen Verschlüsselung kommt, ist ja, naja, die knacken das ja möglicherweise sowieso irgendwie. Und was ich dann immer sage ist, naja, es geht nicht darum, dass es den hundertprozentig perfekten Schutz gibt, sondern es geht darum, dass man diese vollautomatische, algorithmisierte Überwachung einfach erschwert.
Beides, also wenn du es richtig anwendest, und ist ja eigentlich auch, also wenn du dann noch deine physische Security hinbekommst, sind ja so Dinge wie PGP weitestgehend bewiesen sicher. Sodass wenn das fällt, dann haben wir wirklich ganz doll andere Probleme, sodass du dann erst mal mit deiner privaten Kommunikation schon um so was, so großen Ordnungen besser unterwegs bist, als wenn du nicht verschlüsselst, dass dort einfach der technische Aspekt dort einfach schon so gut ist, dass die Ausrede nicht zieht.
Was der Erdgeist gerade gesagt hat, das stimmt, aber man muss natürlich schon sagen, das ist eine Verschlüsselung. Man muss schon auch aufpassen, dass man seinen Computer, wenn man Verschlüsselung macht, dass der eben nicht voller Trojaner ist oder nicht anderweitig angegriffen ist, um die Kommunikation vor oder nach der Verschlüsselung abzugreifen. Und das ist tatsächlich auch so angesichts der Dokumente, die das Noden da hier und da gerade raus tut, das scheint tatsächlich auch noch so ein bisschen ein Problem zu sein. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich sichere Kommunikation machen will, dann sollte man das vielleicht auf einen Computer tun, wo man beispielsweise keinen Webbrowser installiert hat, weil Webbrowser ist so ein bisschen das Haupteinfallstor für viele, viele Angriffspunkte.
Ich finde es eher problematisch, dass wenn sich unsere Bundeskanzlerin hinstellt und so ein wenig damit kokettiert, dass eigentlich sie als Naturwissenschaftlerin, dass für sie dieses ganze Internet Neuland ist, und dann stellt sie sich dahin und gibt dort eigentlich einen Freifahrtschein der Gesellschaft. Also wie ist die so schlimm, wenn ihr euch damit den Details nicht beschäftigt? Dieses Internet ist halt für uns alle nicht neu. Macht euch mal keine Sorgen. Dann wird dort irgendwie vorgelebt von unserer Bundeskanzlerin, dass es schon okay ist, dass man sich mit den technischen Details nicht auseinandersetzt, sondern lieber wie stumpf auf seinem iPad oder was. Wollt ihr das selber benutzen?
Das wollte ich jetzt gerade noch mal nachfragen. Weil also was sie jetzt gesagt hat, das sind zwei verschiedene Vorgehensweise. Das eine ist sozusagen, ich scheiße erst mal darauf, dass es perfekt zu machen, sondern ich verschlüssel erst mal so weit, wie ich es schaffe, einfach um es mir anzugewöhnen. Also so, wie ich mich anschnalle, so, wie ich meine Haustür zumache und abschließe und sage, ich weiß, das ist kein perfekter Schutz, aber ich mache es und gewöhne es mir an. Was Andy dann gerade sagte, ist so, ich mache das auf einem anderen Rechner mit einem bestimmten System, aber das wäre wieder so eine Ausnahmesituation. Also sollen wir uns angewöhnen, bestimmte Kommunikationen zu genießen oder sollen wir uns angewöhnen, das so alltäglich wie möglich zu machen?
Auf jeden Fall so alltäglich wie möglich. Was ich da gerade geschildert habe, ist zugegebenerweise schon ein bisschen das Szenario für den gehobenen Paranoial-Level, der nicht ganz ausbleibt, wenn man sich etwas zu tief mit der Materie beschäftigt.
Ich hab das üblicherweise, wenn du rumgehst, hab ich auch technikferne Menschen erlebt, die in mittelständischen Betrieben gearbeitet haben, denen ich erst mal erklärt hab, was dann eigentlich so mit E-Mails passiert, die sie dort gerade bei dem kostenlosen Anbieter aus den freinichtlichen Staaten, weil ist ja deutlich billiger. Also wir mussten vorher so einen ganzen ITler, und der hat irgendwie unsere ganze E-Mail-Kommunikation so in einem Server aufgesetzt, der gekostet hat, und selbe gibt's da von Google umsonst. Da sind wir jetzt irgendwie komplett zu Google-Mail umgezogen und es ist alles total toll. Dem dann grob zu erklären, dass es deine kritische Infrastruktur ist und du da gerade potenziell das Einfallstor für deine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur jemanden frei hausseln, die Vereinigten Staaten, und dabei irgendwie noch fünf, sechs Geheimdiensten, die da unterwegs mitlauschen, kostenlos angeboten hast, dass das leuchtet den Leuten dann plötzlich ein, wenn man denen das noch mal so darlegt. Und die sind dann auch plötzlich gewillt, diese Tools zu benutzen, die am Ende doch nicht so kompliziert sind wie alle behaupten.
Ist das sozusagen jetzt auch ein Aufruf an die, ich sage mal, uns Nerds, dass wir ein bisschen geduldiger auch sein sollten oder ein bisschen, ja, ich weiß nicht, also Predigen hilft ja auch immer nichts. Aber wie kann man dieses Bewusstsein sozusagen verbreiten?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, weil was meistens hilft, ist die Berührungsängste einfach hands-on abzuschaffen. Du gehst da hin und sagst irgendwie, ich hab dir grad mal dein Enig-Mail-Planter installiert, jetzt kannst du PGP machen, pass auf, hier schickst du eine Mail, nachdem dein Key hochgeladen ist, kannst da auch jemand anders die Mail an dich schicken lassen. Und die meisten Leute freuen sich einfach die Platze. So, echt so einfach, so und irgendwie ist angekommen, guck mal, hier Verschlüsselte, keiner konnte das lesen. Freude und dann ist einfach, ja, such dir deinen Kumpel, Mama, Papa, irgendwas, zeig ihm, wie man seine Kommunikation so schützt. Und wenn dann erst mal das genug gebootstrapped ist, ich versuch's ja immer so zu vergleichen, wie so ein einzelnes Telefon ist nicht sonderlich nützlich. Wenn du der Einzige bist, der PGP sprechen kann, dann ist das nicht...
Du musst halt virulent um sich greifen. Jetzt ist ja aber der Punkt, dass diese verschlüsselte Kommunikation, die funktioniert ja super, wenn man direkt kommuniziert. Und direkt kann jetzt auch so eine kleine Gruppe von Leuten. Jetzt gibt's ja aber dieses Internet, das macht ja vor allen Dingen so viel Spaß, weil es diese sozialen Netzwerke gibt, also Twitter, Facebook, weißt du gar nicht, was und überhaupt. Natürlich wäre die extreme Antwort zu sagen so, raus da. Überall raus da. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren. Ist das nicht ein Punkt, wo man dann sagen muss, okay, da fallen diese Daten an, dann werden die halt auch benutzt? Oder gibt es da auch einen Weg raus?
Wie ich sagte, ich meine, das ist eigentlich ein Geheimdienst. Also das sind dieselben Mechanismen, das sind dieselben Akquise-Strukturen, nur dass denen dort frei Haus geliefert werden.
Ja, also zum Beispiel Erdgeist und Linus sind ja auch bei Twitter. Also ihr seid dann auch beim Geheimdienst, oder? Wo zieht man an die Grenze?
Man kann nicht aufgefallen sein, dass diese Twittersachen, die wir machen, sowieso öffentlich sind. Die würden sie sich auch holen, wenn wir sie woanders veröffentlichen würden, wenn sie jetzt interessieren würden.
Möglicherweise hab ich auf den richtigen Punkt gar nichts.
Ich hab ein anderes Problem. Jemand hat in meinem Namen einen Twitter-Account eingerichtet. Ich hab dann versucht, den mit Hinweis an Twitter löschen zu lassen. Und dann haben die gesagt, wenn du der Meinung bist, dass da und so weiter und fort, müsstest du nachweisen, dass du derjenige bist. Also schick uns mal eine Kopie deines Reisepasses oder deines Personalausweises an die folgende amerikanische Faxnummer, was ich natürlich nicht gemacht hab. Also Twitter ist schon ein Scheißladen, wenn ich das mal so sagen kann.
Ich muss jetzt auch kurz versuchen, klar zu ziehen. Und zwar der Punkt, den du gerade gesagt hast, Linus. Ist ja einerseits, klar, dann steckt sich die Empfehlung, alle sozialen Netzwerke so benutzen, als sei alles, was man dort macht, öffentlich.
Ja, aber selbst das will man ja unter Umständen nicht.
Genau, und die andere Sache ist ja, selbst wenn du sagst, okay, die Nachrichten sind ja öffentlich, man kann ja zum Beispiel aus deinem, wann du Twitterst schon wieder Personenprofile erstellen.
Ja, vor allem könnte Twitter, wenn ich von unterschiedlichen IP-Adressen käme, erkennen nicht nur, wann ich Twitter, sondern auch von wo. Genau, und nicht nur, wann ich Twitter, sondern auch, wann ich dort die Daten abhole, also, wann ich Twitter lese zum Beispiel, also, wann ich auf der Toilette bin.
Das ist sehr schlimm, also, wenn ich irgendwie in meinem Blog Dinge kommuniziere, dann sieht man das von draußen auch, wann das freigeschaltet worden ist. Und da gibt's ja auch Mittel und Wege, aber ich glaube, das ist einfach noch zu klein, weil Twitter irgendwie anders ist es ja eh öffentlich gedacht. Es gibt da zwar ein bisschen Direktnachrichten, aber Twitter ist jetzt eher ein Sprachrohr, während du ja, wie in Facebook, eher, ist es ja so angelegt, dass du da so diverse Vertrauenszirkel hast, und in denen deine Bilder und deine Nachrichten sharest und dann nicht alle öffentlich sind.
Also diese sozialen Netzwerke sind halt keine Netzwerke, ja?
Das sind eigentlich asoziale Netze, weil die Teilnehmer sind ja nicht die Kunden, sondern die Teilnehmer dieser asozialen Netzwerke sind das Produkt. Kunden sind in der Regel irgendwelche Werbeunternehmen oder Unternehmen, die eben Werbung schalten beziehungsweise die Teilnehmerdaten kaufen. Und Twitter ist halt ein Ding, um auch Marketing-Trends genau zu analysieren, um auch Trends zu generieren. Da gibt es denn Marketing-Tools, die genau dir anzeigen, wie was ankommt und wie man dann gegenstört mit so Bot-Netzwerken, mit Shinen-Accounts und wie man Hashtags entführt und so fort. Also das ist schon auch von der Herangehensweise erst mal kein Ding, um Menschen zu vernetzen, sondern um Produkte zu vermarkten oder sonst was. Das zu tun mit den Menschen, zu manipulieren.
So und damit sind wir jetzt am Schluss der Sendung. Ohne alles geklärt zu haben. Alles ist wie immer, Herrgott noch mal. So, bevor ich euch aber entlasse in Henrik Schröders Night Flight, der euch gleich mit Punk-Musik bewerfen wird, noch einmal ein paar, wenn man sich weiter mit dem Thema beschäftigen will. Also insbesondere mit dem so, wie schütze ich mich denn jetzt vielleicht? Habt ihr noch ein paar Empfehlungen oder wenn man weitere Infos will über die ganzen Sachen, die wir besprochen haben? Die Bucket Planet viel hier öfter?
Da sammel ich so ein bisschen die Unternehmen, die diesen Irrsinn betreiben und auch die Länder, die in unterschiedlicher Art und Weise davon betroffen sind. Ansonsten ist neben Klippografie natürlich Datensparsamkeit empfohlen. Und wenn ihr schon der Meinung seid, ihr müsst an diesen Sachen teilnehmen, dann sorgt auch bitte wenigstens dafür, dass ihr nicht Leute, die das vielleicht nicht wollen, da unwissentlich mit reinzieht. Also beispielsweise mit Bildern, die dann automatisch auswirken.
Oder einfach mal das ganze Telefonbuch hochladen.
Genau, und so die ganzen Geschichten. Da gibt's auch diese tolle Erklärung.
Wir müssen jetzt beeilen, noch ein paar Links.
Es gibt eine Webseite, die heißt prismbreak.org, auf der diverse Möglichkeiten, Prism und den Überwachungsmaßnahmen der britischen US-amerikanischen Geheimdienste zu entgehen, vorgestellt werden.
Und ansonsten gibt's den ccc.de, die eff.org und was weiß ich, alles Mögliche noch.
Vielen Dank euch Hörer fürs Zuhören und auch fürs Mitmachen. Das war nur kurz, aber vielleicht kriegen wir es in der nächsten Mahin, dass wir uns dann sozusagen noch mal nach dieser Expertenrunde noch einmal länger darüber unterhalten. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich kann an diesem Abend nur eine Sache noch sagen, lasst uns nicht überwachen. Und macht immer schön eure Backups.